Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim hallo und ja ein schneller folge eine weitere sendung rundum krise
weil es ja krise und sonst nichts besseres zu tun also reden wir mal über
über alles und heute möchte ich ganz gerne ein bisschen über unsere und die der welt der wirtschaft nämlich sprechen.
Begrüßt dazu erstmal den ulrich hallo ulrich.
Ulrich ulrich fass du bist ja auch podcaster da kann man gleich mal voranstellen du machst mit kollegen zusammen den mikroökonomik podcast zu ihr seid ihr auch schon ein komplettes netzwerk mit unterschiedlichen formaten ne.
Ja ja genau es gibt unsere normalerweise wöchentliches format eher so ein lockeres gespräch dann haben wir kurz format wo ein experte dazu kommt wo wir ein einzelthema.
Bearbeiten es gibt ein diskussionsforum mit richtigen ausgebildeten top-ökonomen das findet leider aus organisations- und zeitgründen relativ.
Selten statt und wir machen auch noch eine buch besprechung in unregelmäßigen abständen so das waren so die vier hauptfokus die wir haben.
Da kann schnell wird aus einem hobby eine umfangreiche tätigkeit aber eigentlich bist du auch jobmäßig in anderen segmenten unterwegs.
Genau ich bin eigentlich it-ler,
von haus aus ich hab sehr lange selber programmiert und auch selbstständig programmiert hatte meine eigene firma jetzt bin ich seit ein paar monaten fest angestellt als projektmanager natürlich auch wieder im it-bereich und ja,
software kümmere mich darum eine software und ja wirtschaft war schon immer so ein hobby von mir schon seit ewigkeiten.
Bin von haus aus auch wirtschaftsinformatiker also das ist mein studium gewesen vor ewigkeiten und ja.
Blogger und dann jetzt podcaster.
Also wenn man das so sagen kann ahnung.
Ja ich hoffe ich hoffe ich hoffe vor allem dass ich das gut erklären kann weil das ist bei wirtschaftsthemen aus meiner sicht oft eher das problem um die sachen zu vernehmen.
Dass es in allen bereichen immer das problem von da da ist die wirtschaft glaube ich auch nicht nennenswert anders aufgestellt wenn sie auch natürlich mit ihren komplexitäten daherkommt aber dadurch auch die informatik gut kennst.
Da ist es ja nun auch nicht anders.
Ja ja gut hast recht hast richtig nur alles zurück ja.
Kann man jeden satz beginnen mit naja eigentlich ist es so aber die sache ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Das war ein drosseln zitat jetzt der sagt das auch immer.
Alle sagen das also wer wer wer wer irgendwie halbwegs gut erklären will muss eigentlich immer mit dem disclaimer anfangen den haben wir jetzt hier auch schon vorangestellt.
Jetzt gibt's natürlich die verschiedensten sektoren die man jetzt hier verfolgen könnte um sozusagen diesen den wirtschafts- der aktuellen situation
zu verfolgen
wir haben jetzt auch gar nicht den anspruch hier alles voll umfänglich zu erläutern weil erstmal wissen wir ja auch vieles nicht die situation ändert sich am laufenden meter aber ein paar sachen denke ich sind zumindest schon mal.
Klar geworden wenn man jetzt auf die aktuelle situation blicken,
was würdest du denn sagen was die aktuelle situation im wesentlichen so charakterisiert.
Territory wie wie man im englischen sprachraum so gerne sagt also wir haben eine krise bei der es mir echt schwer fällt aus der vergangenheit irgendwelche.
Logischen klar auf dem tisch liegenden schlüsse zu ziehen,
das unterscheidet die jetzige krise von allen die so in der letzten zeit passiert sind und wenn du zu lange in die vergangenheit zurück schaust
dann hilft dir das halt alles nicht dann kannst du mal ein bisschen was daraus lernen eventuell aber die wirtschaft war dann halt eine komplett andere mit der
globalisierungsgegner grad die vernetzung der wirtschaft die spezialisierung der wirtschaft also aus der wirtschaftskrise jetzt neunzehnhundertneunundzwanzig was zu lernen oder vielleicht aus der spanischen grippe neunzehnhundertachtzehn irgendwas abzuleiten
ist extrem schwierig weil die welt war damals eine komplett andere
also wenn du von europa nach amerika wolltest musstest du ein schiff einsteigen und nochmal so als beispiel mit flugzeug war halt noch nicht wirklich was
und wenn du ein bisschen versucht das aus der näheren.
Vergangenheit zu ziehen die finanzkrise greift nicht weil die hat komplett anders angefangen da.
Hatten wir ein problem im finanzsektor die banken wackelte die lehman ist ja dann als erste große pleite gegangen.
Zu dem zeitpunkt lief die realwirtschaft aber noch und die lief auch noch eine ganze zeit lang weiter bis ich das so dann durch das wirtschaftssystem gefressen hat.
Ist aber nicht vergleichbar mit der jetzigen situation weil hier war jetzt innerhalb von zwei drei ja maximal vier wochen eine welle von kurzarbeit,
die wir so noch nicht gesehen haben also das wird das wird eine rekord zahl geben für den märz oder spätestens in addition von märz und april wird es eine rekordzeit geben an kurzarbeit die angemeldet wurde.
Und in amerika sehen was ja auch bei den erstanträge für die arbeitslosigkeit ich weiß nicht ob du die dieses gift gesehen hast das animierte.
Von den arbeitslosen meldungen in den usa.
Bisher der absolute rekord in den letzten ich glaube fünfzig jahre oder sowas waren da drauf auf der grafik und da war der rekord irgendwie bei siebenhunderttausend oder so was in der größenordnung pro woche.
Und dann hatten wir vor zwei wochen drei millionen drei komma irgendwas millionen und jetzt letzte woche hatten wir sechs komma irgendwas millionen das heißt das sprengt die komplette skala die wir da jemals gesehen haben auf diesen zahlen,
so ein bremsmanövern haben wir einfach noch nicht gesehen wo es so schnell so abrupt die wirtschaftstätigkeit runtergefahren wurde das ist.
Und das halt nicht nur in einem land oder in einem bestimmten bereich sondern einfach überall.
Super super wichtiger aspekt
den wir vielleicht gleich wenn wir über die erholung noch reden sollten dann auch nochmal bekommen weil das so ein bisschen die hoffnung die wir da haben können.
Dass nicht wirklich alle gleichzeitig komplett auf der bremse stehen sondern sich jetzt vielleicht china und asien schon langsam anfangen zu erholen aber,
grundsätzlich ist der zeitraum in dem alle auf die bremse gestiegen sind extrem kurz weil im endeffekt waren zwei monate und dann hat sich's weltweit komplett durchgefressen das ist ihre geschwindigkeit.
Jetzt hast du anderen krisen passen alle nicht so richtig nichtsdestotrotz waren's ja
krisen also es waren schon einschneidende momente und zumindest sind ja dann bestimmte instrumente aufgerufen worden um irgendwas damit abzufedern aufzufangen et cetera also so komplett erfahrungsreise ist man jetzt ja in der krisenbewältigung
bewältigung nicht letztlich könnte man ja auch sagen vielleicht ist er einfach nur eine kombination aus allem erforderlich.
Ja das ist im endeffekt auch das was die politik gemacht hat also ich glaube in der zweitausendacht zweitausendneun krise hat sich ein,
baustein sehr bewährt also,
bankenrettung brauchen wir im moment noch nicht weil es könnte sein dass ich das irgendwann in den finanzsektor reinfrisst aber im moment reden wir diskutieren wenn ich über bankenrettung.
Was aber sehr erfolgreich war war das deutsche kurz arbeiter geld also das hat die beschäftigung in deutschland und auch die basis auf der man nachher die wirtschaft wieder hochfahren kann weil man hat halt seine alten angestellten noch
man hat ihn halt zwischendurch nur ein bisschen weniger gezahlt der staat hat ein bisschen aufgestockt im endeffekt ist die struktur die mitarbeiter struktur in den firmen aber noch
das hat sich sehr bewährt das.
Hat sich glaube ich auch so stark bewährt dass sehr viele länder das inzwischen übernommen haben und teilweise das niveau auf dass der staat aufstockt.
Erhöht haben also in dänemark gibt es glaube ich sogar um hundert prozent,
kurzer weitergeht ich weiß nicht wie lange aber selbst in österreich in österreich ist eingeführt worden kurzer bei der kriegt man achtzig prozent in großbritannien haben sie's eingeführt und selbst in den usa die nichts davon halten hat man immerhin den zugang
zu arbeitslosengeld vereinfacht für eine ganze
teile der bevölkerung die bisher keinen zugriff hatten auf arbeitslosengeld die jetzt immerhin das bekommen das heißt an der stelle.
Haben wir definitiv gelernt.
Ist denn ist denn das kurz arbeiter geld eine deutsche erfindung.
Oh das kann ich dir gar nicht sagen ob das wirklich eine komplett deutsche erfindung ist die geschichte dahinter kenne ich nicht
in den anderen ländern oder in vielen anderen ländern in europa wo gibt es ähnliche modelle umgesetzt werden ist es definitiv eine übernahme des deutschen modells also das kann ich hundert pro sagen.
Also wir waren da der vorzeigestadt in der hinsicht.
Ja okay halt mal kurz fest was das eigentlich bedeutet also kurzer weitergeht ist etwas aus bus beantragt werden und dazu braucht man einen guten grund das kann halt einfach sein dass eine
eine firma selbst in schieflage geraten ist muss die dann zwangsläufig unverschuldet sein oder oder wie was ist da normalerweise das kriterium.
Die kann die muss nicht unverschuldet sein also du kannst da auch verschuldet reinkommen du musst es nur erklären.
Zumindest in normalen zeiten musst du erklären wie du aus dieser situation wieder herauskommen möchtest ich glaube aber diese ganzen bedingungen sind aktuell einfach ausgesetzt weil alle wissen dass es ein externer faktor also wenn du normalerweise kurzarbeit anmeldest musst du sagen,
ich stecke mein vertrieb oder irgendwelche maßnahmen erklären nachdem du da wieder rauskommt aber das macht in der aktuellen situation ja keinen sinn.
Was sind denn noch andere werkzeuge die aus bisher ausgepackt wurden die früher schon sich bewährt haben.
Die sich früher schon bewährt haben.
Also kurzer weitergeht war jetzt sozusagen ein beispiel was sich bewährt hat.
Die meisten sachen die wir jetzt machen sind neu deshalb kann man da gar nicht so viel auf erfahrung zurückgreifen also,
in der letzten krise sind wir ja hingegangen und haben zum beispiel diese abfragprämien gemacht um die deutsche automobilindustrie zu stabilisieren so da sind die ökonomen sehr,
einig ob das erfolgreich war oder nicht oder ob wir einfach nur einen haufen geld in dem moment auf die automobilindustrie geworfen haben,
was dann halt in den zwei jahren nachher nicht ausgegeben wurde also.
Kann aber auch ein erfolg kann trotzdem genau kann aber trotzdem erfolg sein weil wir haben genau in der kritischen zeit stabilisiert von daher ist die diskussion da relativ schwierig und die phase nachher war ja dann nicht mehr so superkritisch.
Da konnte man ja dann auf eine etwas gedämpfte nachfrage aus dem inland vielleicht vernünftig reagieren weil es halt auch nicht so komplett vom himmel gefallen.
Man konnte sich halt darauf vorbereiten und über
gleitzeit modelle oder sowas dann irgendwie oder arbeitszeit konnten das dann irgendwie ausgleichen da gibt's kein keine definitive meinung der ökonomen zu.
Das war damals auch ein großes element was wir hier in deutschland gezogen haben was wir bis jetzt hier noch nicht gezogen haben und die meisten anderen sachen die wir jetzt machen sind wirklich neu die machen wir zum ersten mal.
Diese super schnell angeblich unbürokratisch gewährten kredite.
Sind neu das haben wir so in dem großen stile für jedermann noch nie gemacht also jedermann natürlich nicht ne aber für jedes unternehmen,
bisher war so unternehmensleitung immer eher so ein großunternehmen ding wo man dann halt hochtief oder die großen
man kennt die namen versucht hat staatlich zu stabilisieren aber das jetzt zum beispiel ein friseur oder jeder handwerker quasi auf diese kredite zugreifen kann ist neu
ist ungewöhnlich.
Was auch ebenfalls komplett neu ist sind die ganzen hilfen für solo selbstständige das war bisher immer einer der ganz großen schwachpunkte dass man für die keine rettungs.
Mittel hatte und bei denen die sind halt nicht fest angestellt die kriegen keinen kurzer weiter geld und die unternehmen stehen mit beiden beinen gleichzeitig auf dem
bremspedal und das sind die ersten und die schwächsten in der kette die dann den auftrag nicht mehr bekommen und wo die ausgaben gekürzt werden,
dafür haben wir jetzt spezielle programme aufgelegt das gab so auch noch nicht.
Hat mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überrascht also ich habe relativ schnell gesehen ich meine ich bin ja selber selbstständig kann ja das problem also
man kennt halt viele selbständige insbesondere so aus dem kulturellen bereich ne die ist natürlich sofort mit voller härte traf.
Zumal das ja eben auch so ein so ein bereich ist die meisten selbstständigen sind halt dann doch eher prekäre unterwegs und selbst wenn sie genug verdienen um zu leben haben sie halt selten irgendwelche rücklagen und wenn dann halt einfach so ein totalausfall stattfindet dann stehen sie erstmal schön doof da
und sind natürlich auch nicht so anderweitig abgesichert es gibt.
Kurz arbeiter geld ist halt für angestellte überhaupt ist immer sehr vieles für angestellte und selbstständige ist halt immer so na ja sie zu wie du klarkommst.
Kultur ist natürlich der super,
stark betroffene sektor also hast du ja schon die können ja auch gar nichts dafür sie können ja auch irgendwo mehr auftreten ist ja verboten quasi der ist der geschäftsbetrieb wer untersagt und das ist schon heftig weil ihr immer alle eh nicht gut verdienen.
Vielleicht sind wir an der stelle auch noch mal kurz mal so aufführen wer,
was eigentlich so die ist-situation für diese einzelnen
branchen ist bevor wir vielleicht auch nochmal diese maßnahmen auch nochmal aufgreifen und und und schauen was davon eigentlich jetzt wirklich wirkt und was nicht wirkt man könnte ja jetzt hergehen und sagen okay unsere wirtschaft
teilt sich jetzt so in verschiedene bereiche auf.
Es gibt branchen die unter umständen überhaupt nicht betroffen sind oder nicht so unmittelbar betroffen sind es gibt welche die
extrem sofort betroffen sind aber sich vielleicht irgendwann wieder auch erholen könnten wenn denn diese situation,
weggeht und es gibt bereiche die halt jetzt sofort betroffen sind und die eben auch langfristig.
Teilweise auch sehr sehr sehr langfristig absehbar in probleme geraten werden bis hin zu komplett außer.
Realität geworfen zu sein.
Fangen wir doch mal vielleicht mit womit wollen wir anfangen mit den mit den offensichtlichen problemfällen.
Ja den ersten hast ja schon genannt da können wir daran anknüpfen der ganze kultur sektor.
Konzerte veranstalten kabarettisten kleinkunst und so weiter geht von heute auf morgen nichts mehr jede veranstaltung abgesagt kino betriebe da betrifft er das unternehmen und nicht die angestellten das sind ja meistens nicht so wahnsinnig viel
im kinos der ganze gastronomiebereich mit cafés und restaurants der komplett stillsteht.
Nicht ganz komplett muss man sagen also die dürfen ja noch betrieben werden aber es ist halt sozusagen nur abholen und liefert dienste derzeit funktioniert aber natürlich ist das kann das nur ein teil sein aber sind zumindest nicht komplett geschlossen.
Ja ja okay sagen wir mal neunzig prozent also.
Ja
Mein italiener um die ecke hat mir so eine zahl zugehörig.
Klingt plausibel aber es gibt zumindest noch was zu tun ne während du der schuhladen halt einfach zu hart so.
Genau ja ja einzelhandel dazu bis auf den lebensmitteleinzelhandel das ist ja auch gar nicht ganz bundesweit einheitlich geregelt also hier in nordrhein-westfalen haben die baumärkte zum beispiel immer auf gehabt es gibt auch bundesländer daten die zu.
Ja ganze modeselektor also kleidung die haben jetzt gerade alle ihre frühlings- kollektion im laden hängen.
Und die will im juni keiner mehr kaufen wenn der schotter und wirklich so lange läuft dann haben die die produktion von drei vier monaten da drin hängen und werden den ganzen kram nicht mehr los und müssen oder müssen den hals zu
massiv gesenkten preisen irgendwie loswerden.
Zumal die jetzt wahrscheinlich auch gerade alles was jetzt für frühjahr sommer verkaufen wollten gerade auch erst geordert haben.
Ja das ordern passiert im modeselektor relativ früh interessanterweise weil das ja auch alles vorproduziert wird dann in bangladesch und weiß ich nicht so aber.
Jetzt ist es halt im laden und im lager und,
jetzt muss jetzt eigentlich verkauft werden die haben jetzt ist man wir hatten jetzt gerade die phase wo überall so hier reste verkauft tralala winter schluss nimmt den pelzmantel mit wir brauchen jetzt platz für bikini ne
und jetzt wäre es halt gerade losgegangen temperaturen steigen jetzt hätten alle so gedacht so sommer gibt's auch wieder könnte ich mir mal wieder was neues kaufen und das fällt jetzt komplett aus.
Genau also da wenn der shutdown oder der look down länger anhält.
Geh mal wirklich davon aus dass das irgendwie also im schlimmsten falle irgendwas was ich bis in den juli geht ja dann wird es keiner mehr kaufen also gerade da hängt ja jetzt auch noch übergangs mode,
die braucht wirklich im sommer niemand mehr und das wo willst du an wem willst es dann kaufen verkaufen.
Da kommen wir schon zu so einem interessanten aspekt bei diesen ganzen rettungsmaßnahmen das,
du so bestimmte branchen hast wo es nachholeffekte.
Geben wird wenn die krise irgendwann mal vorbei ist also wo sachen dann halt drei monate lang nicht gekauft wurden aber dann gekauft werden.
So aufgeschoben ist nicht aufgehoben.
Und es gibt halt sektoren da wird das nicht passieren also wenn mein friseur jetzt drei monate zu hat und ich sehe dann aus wie auf der wie friday auf der verlassenen insel dann ja dann geh ich einmal zum friseur und dann ist meine frisur wieder richtig,
ich hole aber die drei monate verpasste frisuren nicht nach und ähnliches wird halt unter umständen
in restaurants passieren da werde ich halt auch nicht unbedingt mein konsum nachholen.
Es gibt aber andere bereiche da wird's dann nachgeholt werden ne also so ein autokauf zum beispiel glaube ich nicht dass die leute den außer wir kriegen halt wirklich lange.
Krise dann ist der autokauf im moment verschoben weil das autohaus halt nicht auf ist und bei der automobilhersteller moment nichts herstellt die leute werden sich aber trotzdem
dann ein auto kaufen da wird ja der nachholeffekte wahrscheinlich ein ganzes stückchen spürbarer werden als in vielen anderen branchen.
Veranstaltungsbereiches generell sind natürlich tief betroffen messen.
Alle formen von events konferenzen ist ist ja nicht nur so dass das jetzt sofort alles weg ist ich habe auch so den eindruck dass es dann eben auch so ein bereich.
Wie auch der tourismus der eben auch langfristig leiden wird weil bis diese konferenz wieder da ist so ah ok.
Man kann jetzt wieder rumlaufen und kann es vielleicht auch wieder einkaufen.
So jetzt so eine konferenz mit tausend leuten genau das richtige für mich jetzt gerade wo wir dann tagelang alle aufeinander einreden.
Da ist natürlich diese unsicherheit extrem groß und ich glaube bis irgendjemand wieder bereit ist überhaupt eine veranstaltung auch nur anzukündigen wird es eine weile dauern.
Ja und da hast du auch eben auch einen kalender ein messegelände da sind die veranstaltungen ja auch so kronisch und da kannst du vieles auch einfach nicht verschieben,
das heißt wenn die messe im frühling ausfällt dann fällt sie aus und dann findet ihr ein jahr später statt wenn sie
jährlichen rhythmus kommt wenn sie im zweijährigen rhythmus kommt dann kannst du es verschieben aber das ist halt bei vielen veranstaltungen nicht so da gibt's die jährlichen dann fällt sie aus und dann ist halt auch schicht bei zu verschieben ist da aufteilt nichts.
Ich glaube die hannover messe industrie hat sich erstmal verschoben ich weiß gar nicht ob das jetzt mittlerweile komplett abgesagt ist habe ich jetzt nicht verfolgt.
Na ja es gibt ein paar die haben verschoben es gibt aber auch welche die haben gesagt wir lassen es komplett ausfallen das.
Also ich wäre jetzt auch nicht
überrascht dass das die die jetzt erst mal gesagt haben wir wir können das irgendwie oder vielleicht können wir das schaffen dass einfach drei vier fünf monate später zu machen dass sie dann einfach daran scheitern werden dass es einfach den zulauf dann einfach nicht mehr geben wird dafür und dann ist es natürlich auch hinfällig.
Wir sind ja risikogebieten mit europa jetzt also aus sicht von asien sind wir jetzt risikogebieten und die internationalen messen zum beispiel da die leben halt auch davon dass die dann die internationale vernetzung hinbekommen,
wenn man das gefühl hat hier ist das besonders risikoreich dann fehlen die leute und dann brauchst du eigentlich die messe nicht mehr durchführen.
Genau was was haben wir denn noch was so unmittelbar betroffen ist.
Gut die läden die geschlossen sind also die geschlossen wurden die haben wir jetzt die andere frage ist immer.
Wir können ja also die leute stehen ja auch auf der bremse sind ja nicht nur die unternehmen die bremsen sondern die privatleute
stellen ja auch ihre ausgaben zurück oder große anschaffung zurückweise genauso verunsichert sind wie die unternehmen die automobilhersteller haben de facto fast
in allen fabriken also ich habe jetzt keinen kompletten überblick über alle fabriken aber es dürfte so ziemlich alles runtergefahren sein.
Maschinenbau wenn keiner investiert wird der maschinenbau genauso betroffen sein.
Die machen wahrscheinlich ist das alles wartung was jetzt weiter läuft aber neuproduktion.
Wird sehr sehr falten sein wenn da überhaupt noch was passiert ich glaube wir sehen das besser wenn wir zum ersten mal die kurzarbeit verzahlen bekommen weil da gibt's dann auch so einen branchen schlüssel.
Und da wissen wir dann genau in welchen branchen das jetzt schon wie stark eingeschlagen hat und,
wie stark da gebremst wurde aber im endeffekt wird es alle mehr oder weniger betreffen
bis auf ganz wenige branchen wie den gesundheitsbereich ne der ist jetzt natürlich voll ausgelastet also wenn du bisher atemschutzmasken produziert hast dann kannst du jetzt halt rund um die uhr produzieren.
Es gibt bereiche die sind halt überhaupt nicht betroffen farmer die medikamente werden genauso gebraucht wie vorher die ärzte arbeiten durch und so dass es gibt halt bestimmte bereiche die arbeiten komplett weiter wie vorher oder halt noch viel stärker als vorher.
Aber das ist leider nur ein kleiner teil der volkswirtschaft.
Trotzdem definiert sich dieser schöne begriffsystem relevanz den wir ja in der finanzkrise hatten und der damals halt auf die banken gelegt wurde definiert sich jetzt auf eine ganz interessante art und weise neu weil jetzt
auf einmal das system was halt laufen muss ist sozusagen die grundlegende versorgung von allen mit dem wichtigsten und was eben jetzt das wichtigste ist
so
Das stellt sich anders da klar wir wären jetzt die banken auch unmittelbarer betroffen wenn ihr natürlich nach wie vor genauso systemrelevant weil das geld muss fließen aber trotzdem
kriegen jetzt natürlich auf einmal auch bereiche und vor allem auch traditionell immer relativ schlecht bezahlte bereiche auf einmal eine ganz andere bedeutung.
Ich hoffe wir vergessen dass nach der krise nicht direkt wieder weil die befürchtung habe ich weil es ist ja auch in in den köpfen eigentlich schon immer drin gewesen ne wir wissen ja dass die jobs wichtig sind im gesundheitswesen
sektor kasten personal im lebensmitteleinzelhandel,
das er fährt jetzt gerade zum ersten mal eine gewisse wertschätzung ich habe aber so gewisse zweifel daran dass sich da grundsätzlich was dran ändert also das
auf der monetären seite an der einschätzung der wichtigkeit der jobs dann wirklich was ändert.
Klar weil angebot und nachfrage so also das denke ich mal,
durfte dürfte schwierig bleiben müll werker et cetera also all das was sozusagen smooth weiterlaufen muss weil man es ja dann auch nicht merkt solange es funktioniert,
ist es irgendwie ja das ist so die normalität nur wenn's halt nicht funktioniert dann dann merkt man's.
Ja gerade also ich weiß auch nicht ob manchmal diese,
entlohnung von mitarbeitern in diesen bereichen also kassen personal ist jetzt für eine ausnahme aber im gesundheitssektor zum beispiel auch einfach da dran hängt dass die leute was gutes tun also dass die menschen helfen,
und dann.
Über diese über dieser entlohnung die dann halt nicht finanziell ist oder monetär ist dass sie deswegen die niedrigere.
Bezahlung akzeptieren.
Weil der job halt wichtig ist und weil er ein gutes gefühl vermittelt was natürlich im sinne des kapitalismus total falsch gedacht ist was so eigentlich sollte man dann auch sagen ich will genauso mein geld haben weil das ist halt auch ein harter job und
das muss man jetzt auch dazu sagen das ist jetzt halt auch ein gefährlicher job ne das ist ja so eine kombination aus beidem viele der jobs die so schlecht bezahlt werden.
Auch die paketdienste die haben jeden tag,
kontakt zu hunderten zweihundert fünfhundert leuten ich weiß es nicht wie viel pakete die so ausliefern und ja die versuchen jetzt die sache nur nach unten an der türe abzug klingeln nur noch und werfen das rein und sagen es zugestellt.
Versuchen den kontakt zu verhindern aber das sind ja halt dann auch in so einer pandemien.
Kritische jobs in italien haben wir's gesehen wie viele mitarbeiter selber an neunzehn dann erkrankt sind.
Also gesundheitswesen weniger bei den lieferdienste.
Ja ja ja genau habe ich das gerade nicht gesagt also im gesundheitssektor die dann einfach auch ausgefallen sind wo die massive probleme bekommen haben die versorgung aufrecht zu erhalten schon bevor die betten kapazität,
erfüllt war war einfach nicht mehr genügend personal da oder eine kombination aus beiden weil die ich selber angesteckt haben.
Und ja das ist ja bei kassen personal ähnlich ne die haben auch jeden tag kontakt mit hunderten von leuten und das ist halt ziemlich ansteckend
da muss halt nur einmal in die einmal einer in die falsche richtung husten die leute laufen alle noch ohne masken rum und ja wenn du pech hast bist du dann schon angesteckt.
Definitiv ein problem vor allem nicht nur weil die kurzfristig ausfallen sondern einfach auch viele gestorben sind also sind ja auch viele ärzte leute in gesundheitsberufen einfach,
sehr akut
betroffen gewesen und wenn sie nicht gestorben sind haben sie vielleicht langfristige probleme das sind auch natürlich leute die noch zusätzlich aus dem gesundheitswesen dann abgezogen werden und die situation noch weiter verschärfen und das ist natürlich dann auch an sich wenn man jetzt wieder ein bisschen in zukunft denkt.
Schon so ein argument ne dass man sagt so wir haben ein interesse daran ein gut ausgestattetes gesundheitswesen zu haben,
so was könnt ihr denn außer akuter lebensgefahr sonst noch so an interessanten argumenten bringen um hier zu arbeiten so ja.
Habt ihr vielleicht noch etwas schichtdienst zu bieten und.
Genau schlechte kinderbetreuung vielleicht so das wäre auch noch ganz gut ne also von daher wäre ich jetzt was den gesundheitssektor betrifft
vorsichtig optimistisch dass ich zumindest ein mindestens ein vorübergehender effekt.
Der dankbarkeit sehr wohl dort.
Zeigen könnte ich bin sehr sehr sehr zurückhaltend weil ich bilder mein mein grundoptimismus an der stelle nicht gleich verbraten.
Denn ich war wenn die sonne erstmal wieder scheint und alles ist gut dann so im verdrängen und vergessen,
sind wir alle sehr gut und dann dann dann liegen dann doch schon wieder neue probleme auf dem tisch und dann dann ist der rest war ja irgendwie ja was ja noch früher die krise und so ach war das schlimm moving,
lass uns doch mal so ein bisschen auf diese gewinner verlierer situation gucken nicht so sehr um jetzt da finger point ding zu machen sondern auch einfach um ein bisschen besser zu verstehen.
Welche maßnahmen denn jetzt eigentlich entwickelt werden müssten weil es gibt ja dann eben auch durchaus wirtschaftsbereichen die jetzt eben nicht so unmittelbar entweder,
hoch gefragt sind weil system relevant auf der einen seite das hat mir oder eben komplett überhaupt nicht mehr gefragt sind
weil keiner will sich mehr treffen kann er darf sich mehr treffen,
diesen vorlaut haben wir ja auf jeden fall deutlich gesehen da gibt's ja auch noch eine ganze menge wirtschaft dazwischen die einerseits natürlich in abhängigkeiten zu diesem berufen steht also wer hat jetzt gesundheitssysteme produziert wird wahrscheinlich jetzt eher noch,
überstunden machen wer aber zulieferer ist für den gastronomischen bereich der wird natürlich auch
nichts zu tun haben weil da werden keine sehr witten mehr verbraucht wird kein besteck mehr gekauft habe all diese ganzen gastronomischen maschinen und wartungsdienst etcetera bis hin zum toilettenpapier
ja was ja irgendwie so eine so eine besondere rolle auf einmal im wahrsten sinne des wortes entwickelt hat in dieser ganzen krise.
Ja also es ist lustig dass kein klopapier mehr mehr gibt weil auf der anderen seite.
Schulen geschlossen haben die ganzen gastronomischen betriebe alle nichts mehr bestellen und es eigentlich nur noch einen einblick in unsere lieferketten
systematik wirft dass das auf einmal hoch nachgefragte produkte nicht mehr da sind obwohl sie eigentlich da sind.
Ja gut das ist dann halt herdentrieb des klopapier ist knapp
und dann sehen alle leute das klopapier ist knapp weil irgendwelche leute angefangen haben zu hamstern und dann machen wir es halt alle nach und denken sich okay ich habe zwar noch zwölf rollen zuhause oder einen pakt zu hause ich nehme schon mal neun mit weil beim letzten dreimal einkaufen war halt dreimal kein klopapier da nehme ich halt beim vierten mal vorsichtshalber eins mit
das führt dann dazu dass ich so ein effekt.
Verstärkt ne.
Dass der lange hält.
Und dadurch erst überhaupt erzeugt wird.
Genau das reicht halt die marktwirtschaft ist halt sehr stark dadrin.
Regelmäßige sachen sauber zu versorgen also wenn du immer eine gleiche nachfrage hast dann werden sich die lieferketten dahinter und die produktionskette.
Dahinter auf diese normale nachfrage hin optimieren und in dem system ist dann relativ wenig luft drin weil wenn die maschinen müssen halt bezahlt werden,
und es gibt in deutschland halt relativ wenig firmen die im einschichtbetrieb laufen sondern die maschinen sind teuer die fabrik ist teuer also versucht zumindest im zweischichtbetrieb zu arbeiten.
Das heißt dann kannst du da noch eine dritte schicht mit der nacht dazulegen das rechnet sich aber im normalen betrieb schon in vielen firmen nicht mehr bei den mitarbeiter dann halten den zuschlag bekommen und viele firmen arbeiten mit relativ gering margen also.
Wirst du nicht so viele kapazität als rest irgendwie im system haben weil der optimiert sich dann raus denn und auf so einen schock.
In der nachfrage also dass da jetzt wirklich so wahnsinnig viele leute irgendwas kaufen also eigentlich ein angebot ist es nicht ne also wenn auf einmal viele leute das kaufen
dann ist nicht so wahnsinnig viel potenzial da und die,
produktion hochzufahren und dann stehst du doof da und das dauert ewig um das irgendwie wieder aufzufüllen.
Was ist denn jetzt so branchen die jetzt so mittelfristig ein problem bekommen könnten wo man nicht so absehbar ist.
Also es gibt so ein paar bereiche die glaube ich jetzt in der mehrzahl im moment noch relativ normal funktionieren zum beispiel der ganze handwerksbereich ich glaube der ist zumindest jetzt kurzfristig noch nicht wirklich betroffen.
Der ganze baubereich dürfte kurzfristig nicht betroffen sein nicht so stark betroffen sein ob das bei den handwerkern so bleibt.
Muss man abwarten was könnte auch irgendwann sein dass die leute alle angst kriegen und kein privatmann den handwerker mehr ins haus lässt und sagte ich weiß ja nicht ob du jetzt nach unten.
Ja ich würde sagen das ist eher jetzt so und könnte sich später vielleicht wieder entspannen.
Also die die ich kenne haben alle noch ganz gut zu tun das ist es das ist unkritisch die investition von staatlicher seite aus die bauinvestitionen.
In deutschland laufen ja auch noch relativ gut weiter also die handwerker die ich kenne da ist alles noch alles noch relativ normal und privatkunden die absagen sind sind die ausnahme,
kann natürlich sein dass da auch irgendwann investitionen zurückgefahren werden oder ausgaben zurückgefahren werden weil die leute dann aus geldmangel den handwerker nicht mehr kommen lassen sondern die reparatur selber machen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der sektor zumindest wenn die krise nicht ganz lang und ganz tief wird relativ gut durch die krise kommt genauso wie der bau.
Da habe ich zwar so auf twitter ein paar kommentare von leuten gesehen die meinen die werden ja überhaupt nicht betroffen oder es gab eine politiker forderung ich weiß nicht mehr von wem sie kam der gesagt hat man könnte doch jetzt bauvorhaben beschleunigen auf den autobahnen.
Es wird ja gerade keine autos fahren und da könnte man die autobahn absperren und alles schneller durch knallen ne.
Bis zu der stelle eine logische überlegung ich kenne aber jemand der arbeitet in der asphalt misch anlage und der hat mir ganz aus erster hand gesagt dass auf der baustelle auf der sieben firmen arbeiten zwei.
Den betrieb komplett eingestellt haben eine erkrankung ein verdacht zack hat die ganze firma hat der chef gesagt risiko zu hoch ich fahre den laden runter.
Gehe auf kurzarbeit und homeoffice ist da halt nicht beim bau so also,
mussten die die baustelle mit dem restlichen personal in den restlichen vier machen also selbst in so bereichen wo man am anfang denken könnte die sind doch da jetzt nicht so wirklich betroffen von.
Wenn die krankheitsfälle in diese firmen reinkommen sind die sehr wohl alle betroffen und dann musst du aus sicherheitsgründen einfach der geschäftsbetrieb darunter fahren.
Also da und das jetzt zu beurteilen ist dann epidemiologische aufgabe also das wissen wir im moment halt auch überhaupt nicht.
Ja das wird auf jeden fall eine.
Für die für die aktuelle zeit ist das natürlich im prinzip so ein so ein fall bei was jederzeit runterfallen kann und erst wenn wir
wirksame maßnahmen ergriffen haben in irgendeiner form eine kontrolle herzustellen
wenn sozusagen erstmal diese exponentielle ausbreitung in griff bekommen wurde erst dann wird man sehen können wie man eben sicherstellen kann durch eben schnelles dressing et cetera die debatte läuft ja auch gerade ganz heiß
hier entsprechend nachregeln zu können um eben nicht alles sofort runter zu fahren.
Ja die frage ist ist halt machst du weiter ne also wenn du eine firma hast mit zwanzig mitarbeitern und du hast einen korona voll in deiner firma.
Kannst du dann noch weitermachen oder werden die alle weil sie kontakt hatten logischerweise wenn die auf der gleichen baustelle gearbeitet haben halt doch den ganzen geschäftsbetrieb runterfahren müssen oder alle garantieren müssen.
Und das ist natürlich auch ein abhängigkeit davon wie viele kundenkontakte du so zwangsläufig hast je nachdem was so deine tätigkeit eben so ist das ist schwierig.
Ja und das macht die beurteilung der aktuellen situation halt so extrem schwierig weil wir so ein fall noch nicht hatten also nicht in so einer arbeitsteiligen globalen vernetzten welt.
Jederzeit irgendwie firmen ausfallen können weil sie immer
weil sie halt den job nicht mehr machen dürfen sie fallen dann ja auch nicht langfristig aus sie fallen dann für zwei wochen aus im besten falle oder drei wochen aus und dann können sie wieder weitermachen aber trotzdem führt das schon das schon für ganz schöne verwerfungen im system.
Jetzt gibt's natürlich auch gewinner in dieser ganzen situation kann man sagen also auch hier wieder in anführungsstrichen also so bereiche die ganz gute.
Nicht betroffen ist ja keiner aber die zumindest.
Entweder interessante produkte haben da fällt mir natürlich vor allem der ganze internet bereich ein
oder die relativ wenig probleme haben ihren betrieb so auf home-office umzustellen wo sich vielleicht viele auch schon so insgeheim freuen mit ja endlich wir haben's ja immer schon gesagt.
Warum muss man immer irgendwohin pendeln um uns dann irgendwie die gleichen langweiligen meetings zu geben die wir auch von zuhause hätten verfolgen können.
Werden wir denn dadurch sozusagen eine verschiebung erleben dass hier ein trend der sich vielleicht sonst eher über einen längeren zeitraum abgespielt hätte.
Beschleunigen wird und damit auch andere teilnehmer in dem markt schneller ins aus befördert die da jetzt nicht mithalten können.
Ich würde es hoffen also ich wünsche es mir natürlich bei keinem dass er aus dem markt ausscheidet alle sollen das machen was ihm spaß macht oder wo sie geld mit verdienen aber.
Sich so sachen wie homeoffice von anderer art von organisationen auf der arbeit durchsetzt wäre natürlich sehr wünschenswert.
Allein um die pendelei und den unnötigen energieverbrauch bis dahin ja einzusparen das wäre halt super interessant das zweite was interessant sein könnte,
das thema für dich wäre dass die leute kapieren wie wichtig dieses nur für netflix offensichtlich gebrauchte internet ist.
Ja
Endlich mal verstehen.
Das erste kritische infrastruktur ist ja ja mein thema seit dreißig jahren der ablenken genau.
Upload genau vielleicht verstehen die leute dass dass es halt doch nicht nur ein download netflix amazon prime videothema ist sondern
eine vernünftige internet-infrastruktur halt unglaublich wichtig ist und ich bin bei mir in der firma wir sind sehr früh in homeoffice gegangen weil wir halt in dem bereich auch arbeiten also wir verkaufen zufällig so eine videokonferenz software,
ähm oder vertreiben die,
und selbst bei uns die alle am laptop arbeiten die alle diese software kennen die alle vorbereitet waren die mit zwei wöchiger vorbereitungen ins home-office gegangen sind also das war wirklich geplant.
Haben wir halt leute dabei mit denen kannst du keine videokonferenz machen weil die kein vernünftiges internet haben.
Das funktioniert alles ist alles da von firmen seite aus aber die sitzen zu hause unterbricht permanent die videoverbindung ab weil der upload so schlecht ist,
das ist schon sehr erschreckend weil wir wohnen die wohnen halt auch nicht in irgendeinem kaffee auf dem land sondern dass es halt hier urbane region das ruhrgebiet so da müsste eigentlich jeder internet haben und es war eigentlich auch jeder glasfaser haben wenn du mich fragst.
Ja es war ganz interessant wo die probleme alle so entstehen und wie du schon angedeutet hat sich für die debatte ja selbst schon seit seit ewigen zeiten und ich merke halt auch immer wieder auch jetzt in den letzten tagen wo ich das teilweise so auf twitter nochmal
thematisiert habe dass das viele eben auch immer noch nicht so richtig verstehen.
Wie weitgehend dieses infrastrukturprogramm ist was was wir da schon seit langem mit uns herumtragen da gibt's dann halt immer so die leute mit so ja mein internet zu hause ist ja schnell genug,
kann ich sagen okay super gratuliere schön schön dass das für dich funktioniert aber das das ist sozusagen
nicht der entscheidende punkt an der stelle weil erstmal du bist ja auch nur mit dem zufrieden was du derzeit nutzt und du nutzt vieles halt nicht was gar nicht existiert weil es erst existieren kann wenn man eben eine bessere infrastruktur überhaupt haben
wenn das jetzt mit dieser ganzen video telefoniererei homos und so weiter erst richtig losgeht dann,
entsteht natürlich einen ganz anderen stellen auf einmal ein druck wie bisher noch mit keinem gerechnet wurde oder wo der einfach sozusagen mit,
wo eingepreist war dass der das das diese nachfrage nicht existiert das fängt ja schon bei den verteilungen an also
die letzte meile sozusagen der
der die ferse eigentlich in deutschland weil wir halt immer noch so viel auf den alten kupfer leitungen arbeiten und dann eben krampfhaft versuche haben übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten zu erhöhen
was dann wiederum andere effekte nach sich zog wie dieses touring dann von der telekom die dann auf einmal diese ganzen eigentlich schon dem markt geöffneten boxen wieder zurücknehmen musste um dann eben das letzte eckchen aus diesen kleinen.
Boxen raus zu melken um irgendwie zumindest so ein bisschen so zu tun als hätte man jetzt schnelleres internet aber dann eben auch nicht mit entsprechenden
öffnung für die upload kapazitäten und jetzt wo sie alle zu hause sitzen und ganztag netflix gucken entsteht natürlich an der stelle auch wieder der nächste flaschenhals weil dann eben die nächsthöhere ebene auch nicht in der lage ist mit diesem bandbreiten umzugehen obwohl das überliegende netz,
gar kein problem damit hatten
also die zentrale der zentrale knoten an frankfurt die haben ja nur dämchen gedreht und haben gesagt so ja kommt mal ruhig irgendwie wir fahren sowieso immer nur auf zwei drittel der kapazität und wenn die pakete mehr werden dann schieben wir einfach die nächsten maschinen in streckung passt schon so darauf sind wir irgendwie vorbereitet,
da können wir überhaupt gar keine probleme aber wo es halt dann wirklich eng wird sind eben an den stellen wo die leute bisher immer gedacht haben da brauche ich ja alles nicht,
ich kenne jetzt so einen fall ich will das mal keine namen nennen von einer,
bankkarte konstruktion mit durchaus etwas systemrelevant die.
Dann so festgestellt hat so jetzt haben wir irgendwie ein paar tausend leute bei uns im im home-office.
Aber wir haben halt hier nur gigabit internetleitung,
und wenn man das dann mal so unsere homeoffice sitzenden mitarbeiter durch teilen bleibt halt für jeden dann irgendwie nur noch so ein kleiner strohhalm daten übrig.
Und da eben auch diese ganzen zugriffs methoden von zuhause auch überhaupt nicht,
optimiert sind da wo dann sozusagen das einzige modell ist nur so ja ich übertrage jetzt meinen kompletten arbeitsgericht meines arbeitsrechner s auf mein heim bildschirm und macht quasi um ganz normale dinge zu tun
eigentlich eine permanente videokonferenz habe ich halt
eine unglaubliche überlastung und diese infrastruktur besteht einfach gar nicht und es ist jetzt nicht so dass die firmen hätten sagen können auch ja machen wir einfach zehnmal so schnell
es gibt diese produkte nicht die existieren einfach nicht wenn man irgendwo hingeht und sagt so ich hätte jetzt ganz gerne mal schnelles netz weil ich brauche jetzt mal zehnfache kapazität,
wissen sie nicht wo die kliniken sollen weil existiert einfach nicht ist nicht da ja es gibt nicht den glasfaseranschluss mit irgendwie gib mir mal zehn gigabit etcetera ist halt einfach nicht da und dann bringt das natürlich komplett zusammen.
Frag mal nach in den schulen
also es gibt ja bundesländer die haben mehr geld oder städte die haben mehr geld als jetzt zum beispiel hier meine arme kleine ruhrgebiet statt aber hier ist nichts es gibt keine infrastruktur ist jetzt gerade aus dem digitalpakt sind irgendwie sieben millionen für glasfaser genehmigt worden.
Die haben aber jetzt ein kupferkabel darunter skaliert halt nicht das da ist halt nichts dazu zu schalten sie können jetzt halt nicht sagen wir brauchen auf einmal viel mehr gut sie bräuchten gar nicht viel mehr weil die haben eh keine
e-learning infrastruktur in den schulen stehen zum großen teil wenn überhaupt dann hat das lehrer in eigenregie da irgendwie hingestellt und da fehlt jetzt alles na das ist
allen richtungen desaster was bis dahin passiert ist und da recht sich halt die schwarze null das war viel zu spät angefangen haben für diese bereiche geld zur verfügung zu stellen.
Unter anderem auch aus sozialen gründe warum hat nicht jeder schüler ein tablet auf staatskosten das geht mir nicht in die birne so und jetzt,
kannst du dann die schüler teilweise überhaupt nicht erreichen jetzt steht da.
Learning server irgendwie da verteilst du irgendwelchen content rüber und dann schreibst du die lehrer dann schreibst du die eltern alle an als lehrer und sagst hier steht das zeug ladet euch das mal runter und dann kommt irgendwie beim drittel.
Gar nicht so super brennpunktschule zurück dass die ja wir haben kein pc.
Die haben kein gerät auf die dem wie die etwas bearbeiten können und das ist so auch eine der,
sache die man jetzt in dieser krise wieder merkte an welchen stellen wir bisher kein geld ausgegeben haben
und wo sich das jetzt ganz bitter recht weit die schere zwischen den kindern und den familien die sich das halt leisten können und die sich das gekauft haben.
Den familien die sich das nicht leisten können die
geht halt immer weiter auseinander es gibt familien die haben kein internet guck dir an wie viel du in hartz iv für telekommunikation und medien
genehmigt chris ich habe die genaue summe nicht im kopf aber ich glaube der medienkonsum ist irgendwie ein euro neunundzwanzig oder sowas im monat also seine unfassbar lächerlich niedrige summe
und wie willst du den leuten jetzt irgendwie elektronisch,
bildungsmaterialien zur verfügung kommen lassen die haben eigentlich da fehlt die komplette infrastruktur auf allen seiten.
Bevor wir vielleicht auch so
die ganzen maßnahmen kommen dir zu ergriffen wurden wobei wir da nebenbei ja immer sowieso drauf kommen mir fällt noch ein anderer bereich
ein der auch auf eine ganz bestimmte art und weise wackelt weil er eben so saisonal so extrem verortet ist es nämlich die landwirtschaft
da kann man halt die ernte kann man halt nicht verschieben,
oder zumindest nicht nicht in dem maße und wir sind natürlich jetzt auch gerade in unserem bereiten
in einem zeitraum wo eben jetzt eine ganze menge auf dem feld bestellt werden sollte
und da kommt jetzt auch noch so ein anderer aspekt mit rein auf den ich sowieso noch mitkommen kommen wollte nämlich so unsere globalisierung beziehungsweise allein schon die verteilung von arbeit innerhalb von europa.
Jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so global sondern vielleicht mehr eine europäisierung an der stelle dir auch sicherlich ein stück weit wünschenswert ist aber es ist ja allgemein bekannt dass eben die feldarbeit in deutschland halt selten von deutschen gemacht wird.
Und jetzt sich im wieder vor der situation sahen dass einfach die ganzen leute die normalerweise jetzt als saisonarbeiter für zwei drei monate nach deutschland kommen,
und dann einfach mal alles wegzuarbeiten was da ist jetzt gar nicht mehr da sind also ich glaube ein paar ausnahmeregelungen sind jetzt schon gemacht worden.
Es gab von vorher so ein ausnahmeregeln also erstens haben relativ viele bauern versucht die saisonarbeiter noch vor dem shutdown,
nach deutschland zu holen und haben die im notfall ein bisschen länger bezahlt auch wenn sie eigentlich noch nicht bräuchten,
aber es ist jetzt auch eine ausnahmeregeln geschaffen worden für bis zu achtzigtausend saisonarbeiter die dann auch direkt eingeflogen werden ich habe mir die details dieser regelung gar nicht angeschaut.
Ich hoffe da habe ich noch einen gewissen optimismus in der hinsicht dass das in deutschland gar nicht so wahnsinnig schwierig wird.
Wir hatten in unserer letzten podcastfolge hat die hannah einen schönen pick gehabt aus spanien und da sieht es viel viel schlimmer aus also,
deutschland glaube ich bekomme dieses problem noch halbwegs gehandelt ich sehe jetzt nicht so dass das hier total zusammenbricht aber in spanien,
wo viele sehr viele sehr schlecht bezahlte arbeiter in der landwirtschaft hat aus marokko kommen.
Dürfen die einfach nicht mehr einreisen spanien hatten lock down einen richtigen lok da unter den namen auch verdient.
Und da ergeben sich dann solche probleme wie das du nur noch als mit einer person im auto fahren darfst.
Es gibt kein mit zwei oder drei personen besetzt das auto.
Wenn du was besorgen musst machst du das alleine so und dann bring mal in dieser situation die saisonarbeiter aufs feld.
Die sind ja auch ein auto da die verdienen ja nix ne also.
Du kriegst die logistik schon gar nicht mehr hingestellt und dann musst du über so soziale aspekte oder gesundheitliche aspekte wie haben die in zwei meter abstand voneinander und so weiter musst du gar nicht diskutieren haben die schutzmasken und so das ist wahrscheinlich unter aller sau was da passiert.
Ja da wird's glaube ich viel viel schwieriger werden und wir bekommen halt.
Extrem viel gemüse genau daher aus spanien mit paprika und tomaten und so weiter da sind anteile also das ist ja nicht nur in deutschland so dass es ja in frankreich und anderen ländern nicht anders die.
Paprika und so die italiener sind wahrscheinlich noch so stolz auf ihre tomaten die werden die garantiert alle selber produzieren aber bei paprika werde ich mir zum beispiel schon nicht mehr so sicher ob die überwiegend dann aussieht italien kommen oder.
Ich meine das ist die frage ob die trainer ist noch in der lage sind das auch alles zu produzieren so und auch entsprechend zu exportieren also.
In die richtung meinte das ja ja ja.
Ja ja genau wir werden ja eher ein versorgungs- auch noch bekommen.
Ja das ist aber auch eins der interessanten aspekte an dieser krise das ist zumindest eine wahrscheinlichkeit gibt dass wir nicht nur so nachfrageschub haben.
Also dass die leute einfach kein geld mehr ausgeben und die firmen nicht mehr investieren sondern wir an bestimmten stellen auch halt auch ein angebotsschuhe sehen können nämlich dass bestimmte produkte einfach nicht mehr produziert werden können weil die mitarbeiter fehlen.
Also über die schutzmasken brauchen wir jetzt nicht zu reden aber das macht die krise auch ungewöhnlich als die krisen vorher bei in der letzten finanzkrise hatten wir halt kein hatten wir halt kein angebot schock den gab es nicht.
Alle die es konnten halt alle weiter produzieren und wir haben jetzt möglicherweise den aspekt das nicht alle weiter produzieren können bei mitarbeiter fehlen
landwirtschaft ist jetzt ganz naheliegend aber den bau des bau- beispiel habe ich ja gerade schon mal kurz genannt auch da können einschläge kommen mit dem man jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht rechnet.
Schauen wir doch mal jetzt ein bisschen darauf wie deutschland.
Regulatorisch und mit welchen maßnahmen reagiert wurde wir hatten ja eingangs schon erwähnt eine der allerersten
maßnahmen mich selber sehr überrascht hat und ich muss auch sagen im nachhinein sehr angenehm überrascht hat war dieser move die selbstständigen zu bedienen.
Besonders interessant ich bin jetzt grad bei der quelle nicht ganz so sicher für diese zahl aber ich habe irgendwie.
Mitbekommen dass wohl in in berlin weit über sechzig prozent aller.
Unternehmungen sozusagen selbstständige sind also dass das hier eine riesen bedeutung hat in in berlin macht man gar nicht glauben.
Aber wie wir ja schon festgehalten gehalten haben das sind sozusagen mit mit die schwächsten so.
Klar gibt viele prekäre schlecht
bezahlte berufe die definitiv auch in die kategorie die schwächsten gehören aber wo zumindest noch ein angestelltenverhältnis da ist und über kurzarbeit eben das abgefangen wurde diese solo selbstständige sind natürlich insofern problematisch als dass sie eben dieses schutzkonzept einer firma noch nicht mal mehr haben
da wurde jetzt relativ schnell geld bereitgestellt habe ich das richtig verstanden habe sind es zuschüsse ne also rein technisch.
Es ist eine mischung aus beidem also erstens kriegst du das geld grundsätzlich nur wenn du auch ein bedarf hast.
Und dann ist es ja auch in den bundesländern unterschiedlich geregelt also da kann man gar nicht ne bundesweit einheitliche aussage zu treffen
die großen pakete also die ersten großen pakete waren bayern und nordrhein-westfalen weil ich in nordrhein-westfalen sitze hab ich mir das ein bisschen intensiver angeschaut in den details angeschaut aber auch da ist es im endeffekt sind's
fast überall mische auszuschließen und krediten,
im solo-selbstständigen bereich gibt es ziemlich schnell geld und es gibt auch zuschüsse es gibt aber auch immer noch die möglichkeit kredite obendrauf zu packen.
Die man dann halt irgendwann wieder tilgen muss für unternehmen gibt es normalerweise eigentlich nur kredite sehr niedriger zinssatz.
Relativ unbürokratische.
Regelungen also du musst normalerweise nicht den ganzen papierkram machen bei der bank den du sonst machen muss wobei da ein konstruktionsfehler direkt eingebaut wurde in das system und zwar übernimmt der staat nur neunzig prozent der haftung hinter dem kredit.
Was die banken dann doch dazu gebracht hat für die zehn prozent rest haftung doch weder den ganzen papierkram entgegenzunehmen was ja was man so
wahrscheinlich hätte vermeiden können indem der staat zumindest für ein teil des kredites erstmal hundert prozent haftung übernommen hätte hauptsache das geld fließt schnell,
das ist ja jetzt einer der ganz wichtigen parameter bei jeder art,
dieser hilfe wir gießen da potenziell geld in betriebe rein die eigentlich nicht mehr gerettet werden sollten oder müssten denen es vorher schon komplett schlecht gab aber wir können die dinger jetzt nicht prüfen das geht nicht wir müssen die firmen,
die eigentlich so gerade eben ihre gehälter bezahlen konnten den job gemacht haben halt schnell retten können und den schnell geld zur verfügung stellen,
da wird halt auch ein bisschen was versickern in vier die es nicht verdient haben aber das kann man nicht vermeiden weil wenn wir alles prüfen wie was normal prüfen wir das geld nie ankommen oder ganz viel zu spät ankommen.
Ja die hilfe für solo selbstständige hat sogar richtig richtig großen umfang ich habe mir hier die zahl von fünfzig milliarden notiert was echt viel geld ist weil wir haben,
nachtragshaushalt von hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden und das ist schon
absoluter rekord normalerweise diskutieren wir über acht oder zehn milliarden schon wochenlang und jetzt haben wir hundertsechsundfünfzig milliarden obendrauf gesetzt
auf den jahreslauf den bundeshaushalt das ist ein drittel des bisherigen haushalts das ist also schon heftige summe.
Ja gut dreiunddreißig milliarden gehen an die krankenhäuser das ist glaube ich auch gut angelegtes geld.
Solo selbstständige bekommen schön geld aber da muss man wirklich in jedes bundesland einzeln in die regeln reinschauen.
Was das bundesland dann genau macht und die zuschüsse in berlin habe ich es auch über twitter von so einigen leuten mitbekommen kommen wirklich schnell,
also das das geht wirklich.
Das hat ratzefatze funktioniert also das ich habe von mehreren leuten gehört und von auch bisher von niemandem was anderes gehört interessanterweise
das also das alles zwei tage spätestens drei tage dabei noch ein wochenende dazwischen aufm konto war
einfach so zack bumm beantragt hier ich brauche das fertig aus kurz danach war es steuernummer ich weiß nicht ganz genau was im einzelnen abgefragt wurde aber muss glaube ich man muss so sein finanzamt irgendwie angeben und dann war die kohle
auf dem konto das natürlich für selbstständige die in der regel ja auch mit relativ kleinen summen arbeiten,
'ne riesenhilfe fünftausend euro klingt erstmal vielleicht nicht viel
aber du weißt halt zumindest okay alles klar damit kann ich zumindest meine verpflichtung für die nächsten ein zwei drei monate irgendwie aufrechterhalten und dann ist der druck erstmal raus oder da kann man eigentlich auch mit relativ wenig geld relativ viel erreichen.
Es ist vor allem auch es ist ja auch kein problem das im nachhinein zu prüfen weil das ist ja das nette an der geschichte das finanzamt ist dann halt verlinkt und du kannst in dem,
antrag nicht nicht betrügen weil die kennen ja deine umsätze die kennen ja deine zahl die musst du ja alle melden und das kannst du dann auch im nachhinein
checken ob da leute den antrag gestellt haben die ihn eigentlich nicht benötigt hätten weil das darf man ja nicht ne man darf fertiges geld nur abrufen wenn man förderungs,
will ich oder oder förderungsbeträge ist um das mal so zu nennen.
Ja ja.
Das ist bei den krediten ähnlich also man sollte sich da jetzt hüten das geld einfach abzurufen wenn man's nicht braucht.
Das kommt dann über das finanzamt irgendwann mal raus ich weiß nicht was dann da an strafen irgendwann hinter steckt das ist glaube ich auch noch gar nicht definiert aber das würde ich würde ich von abraten.
Das spricht übrigens auch ein bisschen gegen dieses gießkannen argument nicht glaube dass das am ende gar nicht so gieß kann nicht ist das geld was wir da jetzt ausschütten.
Dass es schon überwiegend bei denen selbstständigen und den unternehmen ankommt die es auch wirklich brauchen.
Ja ich meine also selbst wenn man
vielleicht muss man das begrifflich mal ein bisschen auseinander halten also zuschuss und kredit kredit halt halt einfach ich muss irgendwann zurückzahlen so laufzeit ist dann nochmal eine andere frage verzinsung sowieso aber der zuschuss heißt ja eigentlich im prinzip ok
hier hast du geld und normalerweise ist das halt ein investitionskostenzuschüsse muss genau argumentieren ja weil ich dieses und nach paragraf haste nicht gesehen habe ich da vielleicht ein anrecht darauf und dann kriegt man irgendwie diese kohle,
zählt aber jetzt zunächst einmal als einnahmen das heißt die müssen ja am ende auch wieder in der steuererklärung landen das ist nicht einfach geschenktes geld sondern es ist quasi nur eine einnahme die ich.
Indirekt über den staat gemacht habe und wenn ich,
quasi dafür gar keine ausgaben habe die jetzt wirtschaftlich bedingt waren dann geht im prinzip diese volle summe eben dann auch in die steuerbereich rein und für leute die halt
wenig verdienen bleibt dann relativ viel von übrig für leute bei denen es aber ganz gut läuft geht dann halt naja dreißig vierzig prozent davon ohnehin wieder an start zurück.
Sich richtig ne.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht ob es in allen bundesländern gleich ist ich habe das so verstanden als das solo selbstständige die der förderung also die die förderung eigentlich nicht brauchen diesen antrag auch nicht stellen können.
Ach so ja das ist nochmal was anderes aber selbst selbst wenn man sie jetzt erhält sozusagen rechnet es sich trotzdem ja am ende dann mit der steuererklärung immer noch mal gegen die realität ab.
Ja ja okay gut ja ja wenn du den punkt meintest ja richtig,
wenn du dann keine ausgaben hast ja gut wenn du jetzt wirklich keine ausgaben hast hättest und du die einnahmen auch nicht bräuchtest dann muss eh zurückzahlen wenn du das geld aber braucht ist und keine ausgaben hast haben ja viele solo-selbständige dann auch einfach nicht also,
oft ist das ja der lohne ihr eigener lohn der der große.
Klar aber es kann ja auch helfen um kurzfristig eine verbindlichkeit dann zu bedienen die man später dann durch die eigene arbeit auch wieder rein kriegt dann hat man's auch gebraucht aber.
Trotzdem
konnte man eben weitermachen und das ist ja dann sozusagen auch eine hilfe bei den krediten ich meine du hast es ja jetzt eben schon gesagt da mit diesen zehn prozent und diesem ganzen aufwand die man machen muss ist ja auch ein bisschen absurde situation weil die regeln dafür,
ja dann üblicherweise wenn ich einen kredit haben will dann muss ich ja irgendwie so ein business plan auflegen und sagen so hier so entwickelt sich jetzt mein unternehmen das ist ja dann quasi auch.
Hinfällig eigentlich für viele unternehmen in der aktuellen situation irgendwie was über die zukunft sagen zu können.
Genau daran scheitern wahrscheinlich auch relativ viele dieser kreditantrag also aus der ecke von unternehmern die wirklich diesen kredit beantragen wollen.
Der nur neunzig prozentigen haftungs übernahme durch den staat da hört man deutlich schlechteres feedback.
Deutlich schlechtere erfahrungen weil die banken halt prüfen und ja wie willst du jetzt in der jetzigen situation den wirtschaftsplan aufstellen will und nicht weiß ob deine firma zwei monate oder vier monate zugemacht wird das ist ja komplett das geht einfach überhaupt.
Und da hätte ich mir gewünscht dass man so ein zweistufiger verfahren machte und zumindest in der ersten ganz kurzfristigen.
Zeitschiene halt eine hundertprozentige staatsverachtung übernimmt und dann kann man ja immer noch wenn es sich das wirklich lange ziehen sollte.
Ab sommer der zweite stufe machen und dann kann man das bis dahin vernünftig prüfen dann hat man zeit aber zumindest der erste batzen geld sollte halt ganz unbürokratisch und ohne prüfung laufen so wie es bei den solo-selbstständigen halt auch,
läuft da musst du im endeffekt ich weiß nicht ob's wie es in berlin ist aber in nordrhein-westfalen gibt's so ein paar.
Bedingungen die da dranhängen das dein umsatz halbiert sein muss und so weiter das musste nachweisen aber das geht normalerweise relativ einfach da musst du dann halt sagen mein umsatz hat sich halbiert und das kannst du ja im nachhinein auch prüfen,
und wenn du dann halt gesagt hast das waren meine bedingungen dann ist es dann kriegst du halt das geld nicht oder muss zurückzahlen ja,
was übrigens auch anders ist bei den krediten was ein großer unterschied ist zu vielen anderen krediten die für gemacht,
gewährt worden es ist ja kein unüblicher mittel unternehmenskredite über die kfz oder so organisation zu vergeben,
es du darfst halt alles über den kredit finanzieren und wenn du eine firma wenn du eine maschine kaufst oder.
Gebäude kaufst oder ähnliche sachen dann kriegst du relativ einfach investitionsmittel dazu.
Da brauchst du halt den businessplan aber dafür kriegst du geld du kannst aber oft,
die laufenden kredite aber so staatlich begünstigte die laufenden kosten über so staatlich begünstigte kredite nicht finanzieren und das geht jetzt du kannst wirklich alle deine kosten,
die du in der firma hast über diese kredite finanzieren lassen auch ein relativ großer unterschied zu den krediten die sonst normalerweise so vergeben werden.
Jetzt gibt's ja noch diesen anderen bereich mit vermietung und das war ja auch ein ziemlicher aufreger medial nachdem adidas angekündigt hat erstmal nicht für seine
läden zu zahlen und da haben sich ja auch glaube ich schon so einige größere unternehmen eingereiht und überhaupt
stellt sich natürlich die frage wie es eigentlich die immobilienbranche hier zu bewerten in dieser aktuellen situation weil die ja sozusagen ihre kunden nicht verliert und,
in anführungsstrichen garantiertes einkommen hat oder zumindest sagen wir mal an der an der forderung ja sozusagen nichts wegfällt ne die läden sind nach wie vor am selben ort
und das gilt sowohl privat als auch gewerblich vielleicht schauen wir erstmal gewerblich drauf
und die sagen halt na ja gott wir haben ja auch kosten und wir müssen ja auch uns langfristig amortisiert gib mal her mit der kohle jetzt haben natürlich all diese läden keine einnahmen mehr oder zumindest viele dieser unternehmen haben keine einnahmen mehr auf der einen seite
mit denen sie das direkt gegen rechnen könnten stehen aber vielleicht teilweise eben gar nicht so schlecht da weil großes unternehmen positiver geschäftsabschlüssen im letzten jahr etcetera wie wie wie siehst du diese situation und was denkst du ist hier
auch das richtige im hinblick auf dem umgang mit immobilien besitz.
Mal ganz vorne anzufangen ich denke mal die kommunikation von adidas war unterirdisch also viel,
dümmer hätte man das kaum machen können als adidas gehört das gemacht hat die haben ja dann auch ein paar tage später noch gesagt wir melden kurzarbeit an für unsere mitarbeiter und der vorstand verzichtet auf,
bezüge auf teile der bezüge die immer noch sage ich mal komfortabel sind und ja,
hätte man das in ein paket gepackt und hätte ganz sauber gesagt wir reden über eine stunde und nicht eine einstellung der mietzahlungen oder oder wir zahlen halt keine miete mehr sondern in der aktuellen situation achten wir darauf.
Dass wir die liquidität nicht dass wir auf unsere liquidität achten und wir gehen deshalb.
Melden kurzarbeit für unsere mitarbeiter an
versuchen die mietzahlungen zu verschieben stellen die dividenden zahlungen ein und der vorstand verzichtet auch auf fünfzig prozent seines gehalts so ich glaube wenn man das in so ein paket gepackt hätte hätte man das viel besser vor argumentieren können,
haben sie aber nicht gemacht und vor allem haben die die weiteren schritte halt auch erst ein paar tage später gemeldet und bis dahin wurde halt nur über die miet kürzungen,
gesprochen,
grundsätzlich muss man bei den vermietern bedenken die haben natürlich auch kosten und dass es bald bei denen sind das kapital kosten wir haben da im endeffekt die gleiche diskussion die wir bei der mietpreisbremse auch haben,
das war ja im ersten zurückrudern haben sie dann gesagt ja okay diese diese miete zahlungsausgleich bezieht sich nur auf die großen vermieter.
Also so große einkaufszentren und ähnliche geschichte die,
normalerweise kapital eignen gehören also irgendwelchen großen fonds oft auch internationalen fonds und die private vermieter in irgendwelchen innenstädten.
Nehmen wir daraus.
Seien auch nur vier haben sie dann glaube ich gesagt ich glaube vier war die zahl und haben's dann rausgenommen und haben gesagt die bezahlbar weiter wir machen das nur bei den großen vermietern nicht.
Gut hat die das auch nix wirklich genutzt.
In der öffentlichen diskussion aber ja man muss schon sehen bei den großen vermietern stecken halt kapital eigner dahinter denen das nicht wirklich wehtun würde.
Aber zinsen müssen die auch zahlen und die sind halt oft auch nicht wirklich solide
also ich kann jetzt nicht darf jetzt nicht sagen die sind unsolide finanziert aber mit krediten arbeiten die alle,
das ist keiner der hundert prozent geld hat und mit hundert prozent des geldes in einkaufszentrum kauft sondern das ist immer eine mischung aus eigenkapital und fremdkapital und die müssen dann halt auch ihre zinsen bezahlen und da sieht man wie sich dann sowas durch das ganze system durchfliest,
dann könnte ja irgendwann der immobilien
besitzer auch sagen ja wenn die mir meinen beet zins nicht bezahlen dann zahle ich den zins vermeiden kredit an die bank dann auch nicht das ist dann so irgendwie
sehr schwierig zu sagen wo hörst du denn jetzt gerechtfertigt auf dein geld zu bezahlen und wo ist es eben nicht mehr gerechtfertigt.
Eigentlich wäre es ja schön wenn einfach alles weiter fließen könnte und diese mietstation idee ist eine echt.
Schwierige ich verstehe das bei privatpersonen kann ich das argument komplett nachvollziehen soll keiner aus der wohnung geschmissen werden es gibt kündigungsschutz und so weiter da ist es eins zu eins nach,
zu vollziehen warum man das auf der gewerblichen ebene so ähnlich versucht hat jetzt von adidas seite aus ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen schleierhaft.
Weil das ich sag jetzt mal ganz hart ist auch deren geschäftsreise ne also warum sollte ich jetzt mit adidas mehr mitleid haben als mit dem immobilienbesitzer eigentlich haben den vortrag und da steht drin du musst deine miete bezahlen.
Auf der anderen seite kannst du deine miete mindern.
Wenn bestimmte sachen passieren ja aber da kommen wir jetzt in so eine rechtliche diskussion also es gibt ganz konkret den fall dass wenn der auf der wenn dein geschäft zum beispiel nicht mehr erreichbar ist weil du es eine baustelle auf deiner straße.
Kannst du unter gewissen umstände hingehen und die miete sogar wirklich mindert miteinander es geht da nicht um stundungen also nur auf verschiebung der zahlung und du kannst wirklich hingehen die miete mindern weil da kannst du als geschäftsbesuch der nix für.
Und das ist dann ein risiko was der immobilienbesitzer trägt der kann natürlich auch nichts dafür dass jetzt da ein jahr lang die straße aufgerissen wird und keiner mehr zu dem haus kommt.
Aber das ist ein risiko was der tragen muss und das ist eine echt schwierige gemengelage um dann zu entscheiden.
Ist das jetzt eine mietminderung die der vermieter auf seine kappe nehmen muss
ist das eine minderung die adidas auf seine kappe nehmen muss die probieren es natürlich an manchen stellen einfach also die sind ja beide mächtig
von gewerbeimmobilien vermieter ist mächtig im normalfall adidas ist mächtig die haben beide große rechtsabteilungen und die kloppen sich jetzt irgendwie aber kann ich dir auch nicht sagen wer dann am ende da recht behält und ob das vernünftig ist oder nicht vernünftig ist.
Ja gut ich meine wenn die großkonzerne aufeinander losgehen dann ist es so dass eine aber du hast ja dann auch genauso wieder tausende an kleineren läden die halt jetzt auch alle haben schließen müssen sozusagen
könnte man ja genauso argumentieren wie mit der baustelle das so naja ich
mieters jetzt zwar von dir aber dein dein vermietungsobjekt darf grade nicht.
Benutzt werden so das liegt dann zwar an meinem geschäftszweig.
Und nicht an deinem so also ein bisschen bisschen schwierig diese situation aber mal so aus einer mit der position heraus jetzt ist ja,
mal abgesehen von diesem bedienen von krediten ist ja sozusagen da auch noch so ein so ein gewinn mit drin na klar.
Dieses an dieser immobilie ändert sich ja jetzt sozusagen so von heute auf morgen erstmal nix also ist jetzt sozusagen nichts was irgendwie sofort.
Aufhört zu funktionieren also es heißt ja nicht ohne grund immobilie und hängt da halt einfach nur rum,
siehst du da nicht ansatzpunkt wo man irgendwo so dieses dieses verlust ding zumindest ein bisschen moderiert bekommen könnte.
Also ich glaube dass in den meisten fällen mieter und vermieter das untereinander aus kaspern müssen,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es da irgendwie ein allgemein gültige lösung für geben kann.
Sie ist wirklich extrem schwierig du hast gerade ganz gut den fall beschrieben dass es nicht an der immobilie hängt und genau das ist der knackpunkt ne der der vermieter kann ja in dem fall dass dem mieter das geschäft geschlossen wird auch nichts dafür.
Das ist das ist das macht die ganze lage so extrem schwierig ich habe da keine gute lösung für wir sind wir haben so so so durchfressen aspekte in diesem ganzen system wo es.
Auch wenn du moralisch da dran gehst und sagst das ist gerechtfertigt oder nicht gerechtfertigt oder kann ich nachvollziehen oder nicht nachvollziehen super schwierig ist da grenzen zu ziehen man nimmt ein friseur der macht seinen laden zu.
Der kann jetzt dahin gehen und sich geld holen aber was passiert jetzt dahinter zahlt er weiter seine miete oder zahlte die nicht.
Personal kann ein kurzarbeit setzen vielleicht dann übernimmt der staat ein bisschen was was macht er jetzt mit dem geld so,
macht seit er den vermieter weiter ja nein ist das gerechtfertigt nicht gerechtfertigt was passiert dahinter.
Zum beispiel bei dem shampoo-hersteller doofes beispiel aber weißt du was ich meine ne was passiert bei den firmen wo er seine sachen kauft wer jetzt in der gastronomie.
Ein entscheidender aspekt weil der kauft ja viele sachen ein während so ein friseur halt einen hohen lohnanteil hat und gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel sachen einkauft.
Soll der da weiter sachen kaufen die wir nicht braucht dann soll er weiter seine miete zahlen das ist extrem schwierig dass das problem.
Kapitalismus also eigentlich in jeder wirtschaft die irgendwie auf geld basiert der geldfluss der muss eigentlich immer im laufen bleiben und wenn der an irgendwelchen stellen auf einmal aufhört.
Dann hast du halt tausend entscheidungen zu treffen die du im normalfall nicht treffen muss und die man eigentlich auch noch vernünftig treffen kann weil der einzige vernünftige fall ist alle haben weiter das geld und zahlen einfach genauso viel geld weiter wieso vorher gezahlt haben und
das passiert jetzt halt nicht und
die nummer aufzulösen weiß ich nicht da kann man nur hoffen dass das schnell vorübergeht und wir das problem einfach dadurch gelöst kriegen dass wieder alle geld einnehmen können und alle wieder geld auch weiter ins system geben können.
Aber trotzdem stellt sich ja so ein bisschen auch die frage nach dieser verteilung gerechtigkeit die ja.
Ohnehin sagen wir mal eingeschränkt ist sehr offensichtlich es gibt schon so bestimmte kondome rate in unserem gesellschaftssystem bei denen tendenziell immer am meisten geld hängen bleibt und es ist halt oft die leute wo das geld ohnehin schon da war
weil die eben mit ihrem geld arbeiten können und ohne da irgendwelche nennenswerte arbeit reinzustecken man hat halt einfach die assets dadurch dass man schon welche hat und die anderen haben halt genau dieses problem dass sie das eben genauso nicht haben sondern es immer nur mit ihrer eigenen arbeit machen können und jetzt wo eben
arbeit wegfällt bleibt auf einmal gar nichts mehr übrig denkst du dass die leute die quasi auf dem geld sitzen,
ist ein bisschen salopp formuliert hier auch eine höhere verantwortung haben und hier vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt nur auf freiwilligkeit basis.
Zur kasse gebeten werden soll.
Der eigentum verpflichtet steht ja in deutschland schon im grundgesetz.
Und gesetz.
Auf jeden fall die liste sehr weit oben und ich glaube darüber müssen wir dann auch nicht diskutieren.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wenn wir an der stelle ansetzen heute waren artikel oder gestern war ein artikel in der feindschaft times und da wurde wirklich eine vermögensabgaben gefordert okay das war natürlich ein gast artikel das ist nicht die financial times linie,
aber man sieht wir diskutieren durchaus über so sachen ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Die stelle des vermieters oder des immobilienbesitzer die richtige wäre sondern.
Ob man das nicht lieber auf so 'ner vermögensabgaben ebene machen.
Sollte wenn man wirklich darüber nachdenken müsste weil du hast wenn du das jetzt wieder über vermieter machst wird es halt sehr grob na du du.
Ich bin schon weg von dem immobilien thema
also das sehe ich ja ein ne ich meine auch da hast du alles erläutert da gibt's fluss und so weiter und pauschal zu sagen jeder der vermietet steht automatisch gut da ist auch albern es gibt auch leute die vermieten halt auch nur mit sehr wenig
gewinnen und haben auch viel interesse daran kleine unternehmen zu unterstützen etcetera gibt's alles und da zu generalisieren ist quatsch mir geht's jetzt ums
bild darüber also sozusagen der gesamte flow wir sehen einfach es stockt geld wird an bestimmten stellen benötigt und es ist nicht so dass es jetzt sozusagen keins
keins gäbe auch ein staat der sich irgendwie kredite holt holt sich das ja irgendwo von leuten die es noch haben also.
Zahlt dafür auch.
Normalfall ist im moment nicht aber im normalfall auch zinsen dafür ja also wenn man einen ansatzpunkt hätte.
Ich sehe keinen politischen willen dafür ne aber wenn man einen ansatzpunkt hätte wäre das aus meiner sicht.
Sowas was in richtung vermögensabgaben geht was man natürlich auch machen könnte was immer gehen würde ist eine zwangshandlung auch so ein ganz altes modell was immer wieder aus der schublade
geholt wird was sich in letzter zeit aber auch keiner mehr getraut hat das umzusetzen wo man einfach leute verpflichtet eine staatsanleihe zu kaufen.
So wenn du hast halt ein vermögen von x millionen und ab da wird dann gesagt es gibt eine zwangsarbeit und du musst drei prozent fünf prozent deines vermögens in diese anleihe stecken,
die dann natürlich keinen vernünftigen zinssatz sondern irgendwo niedrigen zahlende von mir ist auch komplett unverzinst ist und dann holt der staat sich über diese stelle geld wer allerdings immer noch eine relativ.
Falsche maßnahme weil es geht ja nur beim kredit na also das geld würde ja zurückfließen.
Wieder irgendwann wenn der kredit getilgt wird es wäre ja noch nicht eine vermögensabgaben wo man sagt du musst jetzt einfach mal ein prozent oder zwei prozent eines vermögens abführen oder von mir ist auch fünfhundertzehn prozent.
Man kann auch immer über das alte thema vermögenssteuer wieder nachdenken und,
halt grundsätzlich das steuersystem in richtung mehrbelastung von vermögen umbauen wenn man das jetzt hätten wir vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht dann könnten wir dieses mittel nämlich direkt wieder ziehen wir haben aber noch keine vernünftige vermögenssteuer.
Man könnte die erbschaftssteuer erhöhen auch eine steuer die auf die substanz geht.
Das ist ja der unterschied zu den meisten anderen steuern die meisten anderen steuern passieren ja immer auf löhne auf geldflüsse auf umsetzen auf verkaufen öl mineralöle und so weiter.
Und es gibt bis auf die erbschaftssteuer in deutschland eigentlich ja gut es gibt noch eine grund grunderwerbssteuer oder oder grundsteuer aber die meisten anderen steuern die meisten wichtigen,
substanz steuern also die wirklich an die substanz gehen wo nichts für passieren musst du musst einfach nur was haben und zahlt dann darauf steuern gibt es in dem großen stil in deutschland nicht,
ist auch anders als in manchen anderen ländern und wäre jetzt wenn wir es hätten auch einen ansatzpunkt vielleicht kriegen wir's jetzt auch.
Ich glaube aber fast.
Nicht weil wenn die prognosen so halbwegs aufgehen wie die krise nicht so tief dass der deutsche staat an seine finanzierungs- gerät.
Und dann ist die politische diskussion tot weißt du wenn es den grund nicht gibt wird's wieder keine einführen weil diese gerechtigkeits- diskussion der der der richtige punkt den du auch ansprichst die haben wir ja schon seit ewigkeiten,
und wir schaffen es nicht diese steuer durchzusetzen und das steuersystem umzubauen weil es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen die die die ganzen normalen.
Steuern zu senken ich muss ja gar nicht der große freund von hohen steuern sein man kann ja auch sagen wir gehen hin und machen weniger steuern auf die löhne.
Das ist gut weil das schafft mehr arbeit wenn die lohnkosten sinken steigt die nachfrage nach an arbeit ganz einfacher zusammenhang und.
Aber hinten und mache eine vermögenssteuer dagegen und senke dafür zum beispiel die lohnsteuer oder senke von mir ist auch die umsatzsteuer wenn man möchte da könnte man auch die senken ist ein grundsätzlicher umbau ich finde die richtung gut.
Ja es gibt aber leider sehr große widerstände dagegen und in die sind nicht nur in der politik,
da gibt sie grundsätzlich schon immer aber es gibt halt auch so ein grundsätzliches ökonomisches problem an dieser substanzbesteuerung und das ist halt viele leute haben halt substanz,
die relativ schwierig zu besteuern ist,
so wenn du jetzt eine firma hast die fünf millionen wert ist und du musst da jedes jahr zwei prozent vermögenssteuer draufzahlen da muss ja erstmal das geld aus der firma rauskommen.
Das macht nicht jede firma nicht jeder familienunternehmer hat die renditen dass er jedes jahr diese steuern darauf bezahlen könnte er hat auch nicht jeder immobilienbesitzer,
diese rendite darauf
ja klar die haben normalerweise mädchens von vier fünf sechs prozent und könnten dann zwei prozent vermögensteuer darauf bezahlen aber die hat auch nicht
jeder und es ist eigentlich immer schöner wenn du die geldflüsse die umsätze die ausgaben und das besteuert und nicht an die substanz gehst,
ich sehe aber nach den ganzen entwicklungen die wir in den letzten drei vier jahrzehnten hatten.
Befürchte ich oder oder glaube ich dass man in diese richtung wieder gehen muss dass wir irgendeine art von substanzbesteuerung macht dass man eine vermögenssteuer wieder einführt um das immer zu besteuern grundsätzlich oder vielleicht auch die erbschaftssteuer erhöht.
Die er dann nur einmal fällig wird wenn jemand verstirbt und die dann noch den psychologischen vorteil.
Hat dass man da noch sagen kann okay das ist ja geld was du sowieso nicht erwirtschaftet hat
hast sondern das waren deine eltern die das geld erwirtschaftet haben das ist ja eine andere nummer wir versuchen lieber dei die steuern auf,
deine leistung deine eigene leistung auf deinen arbeitseinkommen niedriger zu besteuern und die steuern auf die leistung der generation davor
wo du halt nur glück hattest in die richtige familie geboren zu werden da erhöhen wir die steuern also das könnte man auch.
Moralisch ganz gut herleiten und logisch.
Aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt nicht viel hoffnung dass ich da groß was tut außer die regierung wird mal irgendwann eine andere.
Mal so ein bisschen krise weiß ich jetzt noch nicht aus.
Glaube ich nicht glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was ist mit maßnahmen wie einfach erhöhung des spitzensteuersatzes ich meine auch das ist ja sozusagen etwas wo dieses einkommen dann verdient wird aber dieses vermögen quasi angereichert wird das ja letzten endes die erziehung von
dem gewinn den man eben hat nach steuern und dadurch dass eben die der steuersatz irgendwo bei
ich glaube fünfundvierzig prozent derzeit vererbt und nicht weiter steigt sind dann sozusagen oben auch entsprechende gewinne zu machen
es gab ja auch schon mal andere zeiten wo der spitzensteuersatz sehr viel höher war ja also zum verständnis für leute die.
Vielleicht der debatte an der stelle nicht folgen können unsere einkommenssteuer also das was letzten endes sagt wie viel steuern ich von meinem effektiven gewinn zu zahlen habe steigt an mit dem geld aber es setzt eben demnächst höhere steuersatz auch erst an.
Wenn man das geld hat und eben dann auch nur für das.
Ab dem punkt sozusagen also dass es sich eben auf die niedrigen einkommen nicht nicht auswirkt dadurch,
wer das nicht in den weg den man genauso gehen könnte.
Man.
Wir hatten ja schon mal einen höheren spitzensteuersatz und wir haben auch in einigen ländern in europa höhere spitzensteuersatz e als wir die in deutschland haben,
das ist sicherlich eine maßnahme die man machen kann
man muss allerdings im rückgriff auf die spitzensteuersatz e der vergangenheit sagen dass die damals deutlich höher eingesetzt haben also nicht in die.
In absoluter summe das darf man nicht machen man muss das inflationsbereinigt machen und du zahlst heute relativ früh schon den spitzensteuersatz oben.
Da brauchst du gar nicht da musst du nur gut im beruf stehen da,
it-spezialist sein dann zahlst du spitzensteuersatz also teilweise zahlst du das schon als sehr gut ausgebildeter facharbeiter in der richtigen branche wenn du keine kinder hast dann kommst du schon in den spitzensteuersatz bereich.
Wäre sicherlich eine maßnahme wenn man das strecken würde also wenn man sagen würde wir ziehen die grenzen nach oben.
Und wir erhöhen dafür dann oben aber auch den spitzensteuersatz dann wäre es sicherlich eine maßnahme für die man vielleicht sogar unter den ökonomen eine mehrheit finden würde weil wir wissen.
Auch das über die durchschnittliche steuerbelastung also wenn du wirklich oder steuer und abgabenbelastung sage ich besser so.
Relativ früh in sehr hohe bereiche kommst,
also wenn du die rentenkasse dazu nimmst die sozial arbeitslosenversicherung dazu nimmt die krankenkasse dazu nimmst dann bist du relativ schnell sehr weit oben und der interessante aspekt daran ist.
Dass zum beispiel die einzahlung in die rentenkasse ja gedeckelt ist also da hast du so maximal einkommen ich glaube von sechstausend euro oder sowas im monat.
Darüber musst du keine rentenbeiträge mehr bezahlen und keine krankenkasse mehr bezahlen.
Das heißt für diese leute die noch weiter darüber liegen sinkt dann sogar die belastung irgendwann.
Durchschnittliche belastungen dabei die auf den auf das meer einkommen keine weiteren abgaben mehr bezahlen müssen,
ich kann für die show noch so eine grafik zur verfügung stellen vom deutschen institut der wirtschaft das nennt sich wahl fisch weil das so eine grafik wurde dann sehr schön erkennst.
Das wirklich du sehr hoch in diesem bereich kommst und das dann ziemlich konstant bleibt und erst ganz am ende bei ganz hohen einkommen.
Zieht die belastung dann wieder an und das kommt genau durch diesen effekt dass die sozialabgaben halt nicht mit steigen bei den ganz hohen einkommen,
und das ist ein sehr interessanter punkt wo man eigentlich schon lange mal gegensteuern müsste und wo man am unteren ende die steuerbelastung senken müsste,
oder die sozialabgaben belastungen senken müsste man ja beide möglichkeiten wo man dran drehen kann also die sozialabgaben vielleicht auch progressiv zu machen.
Oder über steuern gegen zu finanzieren da kann man so kann man ganz viel sachen sich vorstellen auf jeden fall müsste unten die belastung runter und am oberen ende hoch und da dürfen wir jetzt auch nicht nur über die steuern diskutieren.
Sondern wir müssen über die gesamtleistung diskutieren es kommen ja auch so sachen dazu wie umsatzsteuer
wenn wir diese diskussion führen welche oft so getan als wenn leute in jedem einkommen keine steuern zahlen das ist ja totaler kappes das stimmt ja gar nicht die zahlen sehr wohl steuern nämlich jedes mal wenn sie bei im supermarkt einkaufen gehen jedes mal wenn sie tanken gehen zahlen die steuern
jedes mal wenn sie strom verbrauchen zahlen die steuern wenn sie heizen zahlen sie steuern alles ist mit steuern belastet und das stimmt ja gar nicht dass sie in deutschland leute gibt die keine steuern bezahlen.
Die steuerbelastung ist immer da und zwar auch bei den niedrigsten einkommen und wenn man das alles zusammenpackt und das muss man,
dann muss man das neu gestalten und darüber nachdenken und dann ist eine erhöhung des spitzensteuersatzes gratis am auch im oberen ende hat eine der maßnahmen die man machen könnte man könnte auch zum beispiel die oberkörper decke für die krankenkasse,
wegstreichen also dass du mit deinem kompletten einkommen in die krankenkasse einzahlen muss.
Gibt es auch kannst du das wäre auch ein parameter den du beeinflussen kannst ok vorher musst du dann die private krankenkasse abschaffen weil sonst gehen alle da rein da passiert ja heute schon aber auch da könntest du dran drehen und das anders gestalten.
Dass die belastung so früh so hoch ist und am ende nicht deutlich steigt ist schon eine fehlkonstruktion im ganzen steuern und abgaben system in deutschland.
Ich fasse mal zusammen also höherer spitzensteuersatz ist eigentlich überfällig so.
Und wäre durchaus auch eine eine möglichkeit sich jetzt hier langfristig auch wieder zu refinanzieren sollte denn jetzt die gesamt belastung durch diese krise einfach in exorbitante bereiche gehen und wenn wir auch gleich noch drauf kommen.
Selbst wenn deutschland hier ganz gut rauskommt wir sind ja nicht alleine wir haben auch noch irgendwie europa und die welt um uns herum und es ist ja jetzt nicht so dass wir jetzt hier über eine krise reden die nur deutschland betrifft sondern ganz im gegenteil wir haben vielleicht hier sogar noch durch unsere vergleichsweise gute
infrastruktur in punkto gesundheit etcetera technik sogar noch ein paar vorteile und stehen sicherlich noch viel besser da
als viele andere sachen trotzdem nur mal kurz noch.
Zu der verteidigungs- gerechtigkeit sozusagen auch langfristig eine debatte die als auch wieder aufkam ist für eine entsprechende sicherung auch unten zu sorgen also
stichwort grundeinkommen oder doch zumindest so etwas wie eine negative einkommenssteuer dass man also wenn man besonders schlecht dasteht.
Zumindest über ein minimum verfügt das einzige was wir derzeit haben ist halt dieses unsägliche hartz vier-system was die leute eigentlich nur ja,
weiter rotieren lässt ohne wirklich eine konkrete chance zum aufstieg zu bieten wie bewertest du die debatte.
Das größte problem an hartz iv ist ja ne
erstens die höhe und das zweite sind die ganzen zwangsmaßnahme und die bürokratie und dokumentationspflicht die da dran hängt das ist halt ein ultra komplexes system ist.
Wo du auch echt magazin krise ganz ganz konkret du fällst jetzt in hartz iv rein ich weiß nicht wann du erst einmal dein geld bekommst kurzer weiter geld hast du nur noch sechzig prozent der seinen einkommens und hat es vorher halt auch nicht viel.
Du kannst dann über hartz vier geld dazu holen ich weiß nicht wann du das bekommst also ich weiß nicht was du dann alles an unterlagen liefern muss und dann hast du ja unter umständen sogar noch diesen vermögens vorbehalt wobei das jetzt sein kann dass der ausgesetzt wurde.
Ja ich glaube da ist.
Der ist ausgesetzt ne.
Der ist gerade ausgesetzt.
Aber im normalfall kommst du ja extrem schwierig an das geld dran so das dauert halt lange der große scham bei den bg.
Oder auch bei einer negativen einkommenssteuer ist halt dass es ja für jeden dann da wäre also du kannst halt sofort.
Dir das geld abrufen und könntest du es bekommen das könntest du jetzt auch temporär machen du kannst ja jetzt auch temporär sagen so wir machen jetzt für den verlauf der krise ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen jeder kann es abrufen fertig wir geben das geld einfach ins system rein.
Glaube dass wir wenn wir in diese richtung gehen dass viel mehr aus dieser automatisierungsgrad butter nehmen uns die arbeitsplätze weg
überlegungen kommen wird und das führt jetzt die kurzfristige krisen- bekämpfung.
Fast nicht geht also ich kann mir vorstellen dass wir auch schecks bekommen so wie es jetzt in amerika gemacht wird wo einfach jeder geld bekommt.
Das ist natürlich ein totales gießkanne ding jeder bekommt einfach geld obendrauf und das soll dann halt ausreichen um durch die krise zu kommen die gehen wir einfach jedem
feierabend hier in amerika sind's glaube ich tausendzweihundertfünfzig euro oder tausend euro pro erwachsenen fünfhundert pro kind und das wird demnächst als scheck jedem einfach zugestellt und dann kann er dann ausgeben,
opfer das amerika.
Sie können mit ai da alles drauf schreiben und sind da weltweit führend aber das zahlsystem.
Das ist eine katastrophe.
Steinzeit da.
Also fleisch gehen wir in die richtung also nach check lösung sondern auch so eine einmalige lösung ich glaube aber nicht dass das bild irgendwie in dieser krise irgendwas werden wird.
Ja gut ich wollte jetzt keine wahrscheinlichkeit abfragen ob ob das sozusagen jetzt kommt eigentlich eher darüber sprechen was
was wäre denn sinnvoll also vielleicht auch mal den leuten die die nicht so ganz in der debatte drinstehen nochmal kurz darzulegen was sich hinter diesem begriff
steckt also grundbedingung loses grundeinkommen sagt halt einfach wir geben jedem ein,
mindestbeitrag zur und wie hoch der ist es erstmal relativ egal da werden alle möglichen zahlen durch die gegend geworfen aber was was ist derzeit der harz betrag ist vierhundert,
irgendwas euro.
Ja da kommt ja dann auch noch da kann ja noch was drauf kommen.
Kommt noch ein bisschen was drauf oder so also sagen wir mal so so in diesem bereich ne sowas was sozusagen hartz wäre kriegt halt einfach
jeder aber wir ersparen uns erstmal von vornherein dieses ganze ich muss nachweisen dass ich das jetzt nötig habe und so weiter sonst kriegt halt einfach jeder dann sagt man so ja aber da kriegen ja auch viele leute ihr geld was was sie gar nicht brauchen weil sie ja wunderbar verdienen bei denen die es halt ohnehin verdienen wird es dann halt am ende auch einfach
quasi über die steuern wieder abgeschöpft und dann ist es eigentlich auch egal aber es bleibt halt automatisch erstmal bei allen hängen die nichts anderes haben und es ist eben
da ist man kann darauf zählen es ist es ist halt einfach da bei dieser negativen einkommenssteuer läuft's halt quasi so indirekt über so naja ich habe nichts verdient ich habe ja eigentlich miese gemacht so und dann anstatt dass ich halt steuern zahle kriege quasi vom staat
geld zurück ne das sehe ich glaube ich ganz richtig so oder genau so dass er eigentlich relativ charmante systeme die vor allem eben durch dieses.
Diese diese diese entbürokratisierung dieses unterstützung
arbeiten und von daher ja auch mal ganz abgesehen davon dass sie geld bereitstellen auch diesen riesenvorteil haben dass die leute einfach auch mental einfach aus diesem tal rausgezogen werden
du musst nicht irgendwo hingehen und betteln und bitte bitte bitte und hoffentlich wird das jetzt auch bewilligt und wenn's bewilligt ist wann
wann geht's denn dann mal los so sondern weiß halt einfach dieser puffer ist immer da und kannst natürlich dann auch ganz andere risiken in deinem leben eingehen kannst aber auch einfach mal sagen so okay alles klar ich brauche jetzt nicht so viel
ich helfe jetzt auch einfach mal,
ich helfe jetzt auch in dieser aktuellen krise versenkt meine zeit und und und kaufe einfach für alte leute im supermarkt ein.
Werden ja alles sachen die dann dadurch eben ermöglicht werden und von daher in ganz anderen volkswirtschaftlichen wert haben.
Es würden auch alle leute bezahlt werden für dienstleistungen die bisher nicht bezahlt werden zum beispiel alle,
erziehenden zum beispiel ganz doof ne oder die kriegen ja im moment de facto kein geld bis auf das kindergeld dann vielleicht ne aber ja also die das modell grundsätzlich hat scham.
Die diskussion hängt massiv daran ob man das bedingungslos macht also an der stelle bedingungslos das für mich wäre das ein.
Ganz wichtiger aspekt so das gegenargument was an der stelle kommt ist aber immer sofort du hast ja gerade schon kurz genannt gießkanne und du gibst auch geld leuten die es eigentlich nicht benötigen.
Man muss durchrechnen was das alles kostet in dem system,
eventuell gibt's ja auch da zusätzliche einnahmen das problem ist lässt oder drei ökonomen das ding durchrechnen kriegst du zehn ergebnisse.
Und das ist im vorfeld auch extrem schwierig zu beurteilen was sowas kosten würde.
Die ganze grundidee bei vielen verfechtern.
Geht aber auch in eine andere richtung also auch auf ein anderes niveau also da reden wir nicht bei hartz iv und so eine summe geld die einfach jeder bekommt sondern es gibt ja viele verfechter die glauben dass das komplett.
Für immer und nicht nur für not phasen sondern für immer ein richtiges vernünftiges einkommen darstellen sollte.
So dass du im endeffekt auch grundsätzlich sagen könntest ich verzichte auf einen job ich mache dann halt vielleicht auch aber ich kann so die götz werner idee d s g m gründers ist ja auch so dass er
offiziell dagegen rechnet dass der stundenlohn dann ja auf zwei euro sinken könnte weil man ja schon genügend geld vom staat bekommt.
Das sind dann aber komplett andere modelle also das ist was anderes als zu sagen ich ersetze hartz iv oder von mir ist auch eine rente mindestrente.
Durch hartz iv so und dann durch hartz iv durch den weg und ersetze alles was an mindestlohn im moment im sozialsystem geleistet wird halt durch ein
das ist mal was anderes als wenn du über tausend oder tausendzweihundert oder tausendfünfhundert euro im monat diskutiert das sind da natürlich nochmal komplett unterschiedliche modelle und das
das ist eine ganz die diskussion ist deswegen schon so schwierig weil die leute sich gar nicht darauf einigen können was einen eigentlich ist und wie hoch ist sein sollte,
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass du auf diesem.
Grund auf diesem absoluten minimum niveau da durchaus eine einigung für hinbekommen würdest.
Da gibt's auch im politischen bereich ein paar leute die das gut finden es gibt aber immer noch sehr viele leute die immer.
Über arbeit nachdenken also für die grundsätzlich ein einkommen nicht okay ist wenn du nicht arbeiten willst.
Beim steht halt bedingungslos im namen und bedingungslos heißt.
Du kannst halt tun und lassen was du willst wenn du willst arbeitest du halt zusätzlich noch und holst dir noch ein paar euro mehr raus und wenn du nicht willst machst du es halt nicht und das ist der gedankliche sprung den sehr viele einfach nicht,
hinbekommen also die ganzen gewerkschafter zum beispiel die können sich das nicht vorstellen dass du geld bekommst ohne zu arbeiten die definieren sich halt über arbeit das ist.
Und.
Viele leute die einfach arbeiten ohne dafür geld zu bekommen das hat mir schon beispiel haushalt und es gibt halt auch viele leute die können halt nicht arbeiten so,
und zwar entweder weil sie mental gesundheitlich körperlich dazu nicht in der lage sind und derzeit ja sozusagen auch unterstützung bekommen vom staat also die uns so ohnehin geld kosten also zurecht geld kosten ja weil weil es,
irgendwo ja auch klar ist dass wir keine bessere gesellschaft dadurch werden dass wir den schwächsten
sozusagen die linksextremistenp nehmen weil es uns das am ende erstmal sowieso also erstmal ethisch moralisch sowieso nicht okay ist aber darüber hinaus am ende sehr viel mehr,
kostet wenn man sozusagen so viele notfälle hat und man sieht es ja auch mit anderen problemen obdachlosigkeit et cetera verwahrlosung das arbeitslosigkeit extreme also wenn leute dann sozusagen in in not sind
werden sie ja dann nochmal doppelt und dreifach zum problem kriminalität etcetera krankheit was da alles noch mit dran hängt das sind ja alles kosten die man da eben durchaus noch mal mit rein rechnen müsste sodass ebenso aus meiner perspektive am ende sozusagen so ein minimales grundeinkommen was der eigentlich immer nur signalisiert okay
du kannst davon nicht leben im sinne von so wie du leben möchtest aber du kannst davon immer überleben.
So dass ihr diese überlebensangst genommen wird das wäre sozusagen etwas was auch gerade in solchen krisensituationen alle sofort entspannen würde mit ok luxus fällt jetzt weg ja und es wird jetzt auch kein lustiges jahr,
aber ich werde mir nicht darum morgen darüber gedanken machen so wie wir das jetzt in den usa haben wo du es drei kilometer lange schlangen hast an den tafel ausgaben um überhaupt essen zu bekommen von leuten die,
gestern gerade entlassen wurden ja
dass das dann sozusagen erstmal dein dein nächstes problem ist wie überlebe ich denn überhaupt den nächsten tag das ist ja schon nochmal ein heftiger sprung und deswegen fand ich das einfach mal ganz wertvoll darüber diskutiert zu haben ohne jetzt hier die grundsatz des kusses
grundeinkommen und zwar das ist schon klar dass das
enorme konsequenzen hat und eine eine eine debatten reichtum hat ne,
wir müssen uns natürlich jetzt schon auch darüber gedanken machen in dieser situation weil wann denn sonst
was für modelle stehen dann sozusagen noch an weil jetzt kann man ja auch mal wach in die krise reinschauen und sagen ok was haben wir denn jetzt hier für dynamiken am start was für probleme treten auf einmal auf mit dem wir so nie gerechnet haben wie würde sich denn das verhalten wenn.
Das und das ohnehin schon anders geregelt worden wäre das finde ich jetzt sozusagen den sportlichen aspekt an dieser stelle.
Das ist ja sehr wichtig wir konnten wir hätten uns in vielerlei hinsicht besser auf die krise vorbereiten können ne also jetzt wenn man jetzt mal auf die europäische ebene denkt ich glaube das werden wir im detail nicht mehr diskutieren aber über diese eurobonds geschichte und
finanzierung auf europäischer ebene dann reden ja auch da hätten wir uns zweitausendzehn zweitausendzwölf haben wir alle probleme auf dem tisch gehabt und da hätten wir sie lösen können
ich glaube auch dass unser sozialsystem an vielen stellen viel zu kompliziert ist und es
hilfreich gewesen wäre dass man zu vereinfachen und eben dieses bedingungslos da einzuziehen dann könnten wir uns ja alles mögliche sparen bafög und mindestrente und.
Würde vieles vereinfachen und ja.
Jetzt haben wir diese.
Situation ja das eben corona überall auswirkungen hat und wir sehen natürlich dass in europa.
Erstmal noch gar nicht absehbar ist.
Wer eigentlich am stärksten betroffen sein wird aber es gibt auf jeden fall schon mal ein paar kandidaten italien und spanien haben wir schon erwähnt dass es ganz offensichtlich der rest
entwickelt sich gerade noch ich habe so die befürchtung dass unser sorgenkind großbritannien nochmal
besondere beiträge leisten wird zur situationen verschärfung.
Vom rest business nicht osteuropa steht ohnehin schon immer relativ schwach da und
bisher tut sich so auf europäischer ebene gefühlt relativ wenig und auch da sind wir wieder erinnert an diese finanzkrise das ist ja auch schon erwähnt so okay was ist denn jetzt eigentlich hier müssen wir denn nicht mal langsam darüber nachdenken so wie die wie der bund für die länder und für die gesamtheit der
bundesrepublik deutschland eintritt und hier gemeinsame pläne und maßnahmen macht dass wir auch auf europäischer ebene sagen müssen
das betrifft uns alle dass wir ist europa jetzt haben wir so lange sonntagsreden gehalten zu diesem bereich,
jetzt kannst du ja wohl nicht sein dass wir auf der ebene ausgerechnet survival of the fit ist spielen und,
sagen jetzt ja mal früher drüber nachdenken können.
Ja du italien spanien sind wahrscheinlich die beiden im moment interessantesten fell weil dort
zahl der erkrankung erstens hoch ist die zahl der todesfälle sehr hoch ist das gesundheitssystem in einigen regionen komplett überlastet ist und es ist auch echt noch ein bisschen dauern wird bis ich das erholt
und weil die ihre wirtschaft massiv runtergefahren haben die ernte hälfte ein spanien habe ich ja gerade schon genannt aber in
italien ist es ja auch so dass im endeffekt die komplette.
Nicht lebensnotwendige industrie runtergefahren wurde also der lok down hat da ein ganz anderes ausmaß als es hier in deutschland hat wo ja jeder noch arbeiten gehen darf aus erarbeitet halt gerade im cafe oder im einzelhandel,
sonst ist das meiste noch offen und läuft noch.
Es war auch sehr viel zu aber in italien ist es halt noch viel viel viel viel extremer das problem ist beide länder spanien.
Ist hochverschuldet italien eigentlich schon sehr sehr hoch mit über hundertdreißig prozent des bips das heißt.
Die haben nicht mehr so wirklich viel geld dass sie sich als staatsschulden neu obendrauf packen könnten.
Dummerweise sind dass die länder die am meisten geld bräuchten und die maßnahmen die deutschland eingeleitet hat sind.
Auf das auf die wirtschaftsleistung bezogen deutlich umfangreicher als das was italien und spanien bisher in die hand nehmen konnten und das liegt eben daran das ist auch nicht wirklich,
dürfen okay die schuldenbremse ist aufgehoben das heißt die gilt nicht mehr in deutschland nicht mehr und die regeln innerhalb der eu oder innerhalb der eurozone gelten auch nicht mehr starten können im endeffekt schulden aufnehmen so viel wie sie wollen.
Italien würde es aber einfach nicht mehr an den anleihe märkten oder eine kapitalmärkten finanziert bekommen.
Die summen die da auch nochmal oben drauf kommen da wachsen die schulden halt in die höhe in die griechenland auch gekommen ist wo.
Und den dann auch keiner mehr geld geben wollten war alle angst um ihre rückzahlung an.
Das ist die die gemengelage die die das geld am nötigsten hätten und das meiste geld am nötigsten hätten kommen am schwierigsten dran.
Und vor allem wenn ich das noch hinzufügen darf wir sehen auch gerade in spanien und italien ein problem mit dem gesundheitssystem dass auch die folge des sparens ist,
seit der letzten finanzkrise da waren diese länder gezwungen
durch diese durch diese durch dieses dogma der austeritätspolitik ihre staatshaushalte entsprechend runterzufahren und wo haben sie halt gespart,
nicht nur da aber eben auch im gesundheitssystem und das fällt ihnen natürlich jetzt doppelt auf die füße.
Ja ich habe dazu mal die zahlen rausgesucht und dieser aspekt ist gar nicht so extrem wie ich ihn erwartet hätte,
zumindest wenn man die euro stadt zahlen nimmt sind die ausgaben im gesundheitssektor was das angeht sogar in beiden ländern relativ konstant geblieben wirklich.
Sich massiv.
Totgespart muss man schon sagen hat sich griechenland also da ist ja nicht nur die wirtschaftsleistung massiv zurückgegangen sondern da sind auch die gesundheitsausschuss haben zurückgegangen so jetzt sind das sehr grobe zahlen man kann auch noch weitere zahlen nehmen wie zum betten,
anzahl pro kopf und so geschichten die sind auch gesunken aber jetzt nicht übermäßig die waren schon,
vorher niedrig und das ist eher so dieser aspekt den man glaube ich machen müsste die haben vorher schon zu wenig geld für ihr gesundheitssystem ausgegeben.
Und geben immer noch zu viel zu wenig geld aus so so ist ungefähr so die lage wirklich massiv zusammengespart hat
griechenland das gesundheitssystem ja aber die ausgaben davon unabhängig in deutschland sind natürlich deutlich gestiegen also die,
in prozent des bips ist es leicht gestiegen aber in deutschland ist halt auch das bip gestiegen was es in italien und spanien hat nicht gemacht hat und in griechenland ist es ja sogar massiv geschrumpft
das ist ja die ausgangslage und deshalb haben die.
Also das sind jetzt so sehr grobe zahlen von ganz oben gesehen da sagt ja immer noch nichts über die qualität im gesundheitssystem aus also sowas wie betten anzahl sagt überhaupt nichts aus jetzt über diese intensivpflege
betten also da wo wirklich ein beatmungsgeräte dranhängt und.
Da hängt auch noch einen personalschlüssel noch mit dran.
Personalschlüssel hängt dran da hängen labor kapazitäten dran eine ganz groß diskutiertes problem im moment,
wir in deutschland halt labor kapazitäten hatten und die sogar relativ schnell echt kräftig ausbauen konnten.
In spanien und in italien so vielleicht gar nicht möglich ist kann ich nichts zu sagen man findet da keine verlässlichen zahlen zu befinden ja nichtmals verlässliche zahlen zu den labor kapazitäten oder test kapazitäten in deutschland das ist ja schon fast drei leute und bekommst fünf zahlen genannt
wie das in spanien italien aussieht weiß ich nicht,
gäbe da eine interessante zahl da habe ich nachgeschaut die wird aber genau für die länder nicht geliefert und vor allem für deutschland auch nicht geliefert das heißt da kann man nichts raus ableiten.
Man kann,
griechenland mit frankreich vergleichen aber alle anderen wichtigen zahlen die wir jetzt von den ländern genannt haben die fehlen leider das sind die investitionen ins gesundheitssystem in prozent des bips das wäre eine interessante zahl weil dann könnte man auch den bau von krankenhäusern,
teure maschinen leer kapazität und sowas zählen die zahl haben wir leider nicht naja.
Was war deine frage noch mag jetzt habe ich so viel zu dem einen punkt gesagt.
Naja generell wie gehen wir jetzt sozusagen um also welche art der solidarität leiten wir denn jetzt sozusagen
ab aus dieser situation dass um uns herum und ich meine wir müssen auch klar machen unsere relativ starke wirtschaftliche situation hängt auch viel mit export ab so und wenn wir
all diese länder jetzt zugrundegehen lassen ja die uns nicht nur irgendwie gemüse liefern sondern für die die auch auch für uns wichtige abnehmer sind.
Auch mal hier wieder,
ganz abgesehen davon dass wir dass ich schon finde dass es da so eine ethisch moralischen verpflichtungen gibt insbesondere im kontext dieser immer wieder gebetsmühlenartig wiederholten europäischen solidarität die wir jetzt angeblich wieder neu gefunden haben nach dem brexit et cetera und wir haben uns ja sowieso lieb und,
warum ist es nicht möglich das konkret auch deutschland ein willigt und sagt gut,
die usa nehmen kredit für die ganze für für alle fünfzig bundesstaaten auf warum,
treten wir nicht als europäische union als kreditnehmer der welt gegenüber und es summiert sich unsere kredit würdigkeit.
Ja in der eurokrise hatten wir die ganze diskussion ja schon,
und das hauptargument dagegen weil immer wir müssen die kreditvergabe und die haftung zusammen lassen also wenn ein bund eine anleihe rausgegeben wird eine staatsanleihe dann haftet der staat dafür.
Ich verstehe diese logik am ende nicht wirklich ich war immer ein verfechter von eurobonds sehe aber.
Die politische diskussion hat sich überhaupt
nicht weiterentwickelt habe ich so das gefühl wenn ich das von außen betrachte weil da wird dann sofort mit argumentiert ja die idee hatten wir ja schon mal auf den tisch und die haben wir schnell wieder in die schublade zurückgesteckt,
da wird sich nicht mals mit den argumenten auseinandergesetzt die damals dafür gesprochen haben und die heute auch noch dafür sprechen nämlich man.
Einen bestimmten teil man muss es ja gar nicht für die komplette staatsschulden machen also man kann ja auch sagen wir machen das nur bis zum bestimmten niveau wir haben in maastricht mal irgendwann sechzig prozent der wirtschaftsleistung für jeden staat als schulden grenze definiert
legen ja fast alle drüber deutschland.
Letztes jahr mal ausnahmsweise glaube ich nicht jetzt mit der erhöhung des bundeshaushalts werden wir auch für darüber legen und alle anderen liegen ja mehr oder weniger darüber und da könnte man ja sagen man finanziert den unteren teil selber.
Also meine finanziert den unteren teil gemeinsam alle zusammen bei auf die summe haben wir uns halt mal irgendwann geeinigt und nimm den teil oben drüber und lässt den weiterhin in staats.
Wir werden auch einen kompromiss um dieses haftung nicht in unendliche höhen gehen zu lassen wo er einige leute offensichtlich richtig angst vorhaben ich verstehe es.
Nicht.
Aber so ist halt die diskussion es wird halt direkt wieder totgeschlagen was jetzt noch dazu kommt ist wir hätten jetzt noch eine viel bessere chance unter noch genauer definieren bedingungen.
Diese gemeinsamen staatsanleihen aufzulegen also diese europäischen staatsanleihen gemeinsam nämlich an ein ereignis gekoppelt.
An diese corona gekoppelt die staatsanleihen aufzugeben da könnte man sogar dafür sorgen dass alles was über dieses mittel an geld in den staatshaushalt fließt auch für maßnahmen gegen,
den virus oder gegen die krise auszugeben.
Also kurz arbeiter geld bürgschaften für unternehmen geld für krankenhäuser.
Kann man ja politisch definieren da gibt es ja sehr viele möglichkeiten zu sagen das ist eine sinnvolle ausgabe im zusammenhang,
mit der krise und das sind halt keine und dann kannst du die sinnvollen ausgaben über
diese anleihe über diese gemeinsame anleihe für die alle staaten gemeinsam haften die ja auch alle gemeinsam betroffen sind das macht ja auch sinn das kannst du ja logisch logisch verargumentieren an dieser stelle da musst du ja gar nicht mit europäischem gedanken und so ein kram
kommen du könntest auch was sagen es sind ja auch einfach alle betroffen also legen wir alle zusammen eine anleihe auf der
musst du hier diese europäische schiene noch gar nicht aufnehmen sondern sagst da kann sich halt jeder geld drüber besorgen weil wir sind alle betroffen und alle haften gemeinsam dafür.
Corona bonds.
Genau.
Im endeffekt ja die konstruktion sehr ähnlich wie damals bei den eurobonds nur wäre das jetzt konkret an dieses ereignis noch gekoppelt und damit es noch noch schöner definiert und es wäre eben auch klar das muss so nach x jahren zurückzahlen.
Wenn du jetzt ganz hart drauf bist machst du die laufzeit kurz und du sagst
finanziert sie nur für fünf jahre und dann sollen die länder wieder für sich selber sorgen weil wir haben ja dann halt ihre eigenen anleihen soll sich selber drum kümmern wer die harte variante du kannst aber auch sagen da machen wir eine dreißigjährige anleihe raus.
Würde am anleihemarkt garantiert gekauft mit einer gemeinschaftshaus und des der zins wäre wahrscheinlich auch nicht,
hoch wenn alle gemeinsam dafür haften und dann lässt man es ganz lange laufen und sagt dann halt den staaten ihr kriegt eine langfristige entlastung auf eurer zins ausgabenseite.
Die griechischen anleihen laufen ja jetzt im endeffekt auch alle so lange die sind ja da hat man sich auch jedes mal um die bedingungen gekloppt.
Und wochenlang und da war wieder alles auf messers schneide und keine der bedingungen die damals vereinbart wurde ist gehalten worden,
nichts davon hat gehalten wir haben die zinsen mehrfach gesenkt wir haben die laufzeiten verlängert wir haben nach dem ersten rettungsprogramm ein zweites aufgelegten drittes aufgelegt und so weiter obwohl wir die immer ausgeschlossen haben und,
eigentlich war die ganze diskussion also total verlogen an der stelle weil man hat immer sachen als endgültig und da er machen wir nichts dran definiert und man hat trotzdem immer wieder alles geändert und ich,
glaube dass irgendwie wieder in so eine richtung geht wir wieder wochenlange sinnlose diskussionen bekommen statt das jetzt einmal vom tisch zu erwischen das thema den bond aufzulegen zu sagen so fünfzehn prozent des bips zwanzig prozent des bips.
Machen wir gemeinsam zweckgebunden wie ein uns einmal auf den auf die laufzeit und gut ist.
Tja und warum machen sie mal macht das denn keiner.
Ich weiß es nicht weil der altmaier hat sofort gesagt kein geld für italien das war glaube ich wirklich die überschrift im spiegel darüber und es gibt so ein paar ökonomen.
Den ist unfassbar wichtig ist dass die haftung und die.
Kredite nicht auseinander laufen dass immer einer dafür haftet und ich verstehe das nicht.
Klar es macht in argumentation irgendwo.
Sinn weil wir haben halt nationalstaaten die weiterhin die steuern erheben ideen gewählt wird alleine und wir sind halt an vielen stellen bei der europäischen union nicht wirklich weiter gekommen in den letzten.
Mindestens in dem letzten jahrzehnt und wir haben jetzt die zweite krise in der man eigentlich mal diese europäische integration voranbringen sollte und in diese richtung gehen sollte das wäre halt zusammen anleihen haben das wäre vielleicht auch zusammen gesteuert erheben.
Dass das europäische parlament und brüssel noch wichtiger wird aber da sind wir halt an den ganzen entscheidenden stellen nicht weitergekommen
in den letzten jahren und deshalb stehen wir jetzt bei der anleihe geschichte auch wieder da das da im endeffekt politische verantwortung und haftung und kredit auseinanderlaufen und wir uns jetzt wieder auf irgendwas einigen müssen
wo man schon lange hätte ein fundament verlegen müssen um den mist gar nicht mehr diskutieren zu müssen.
Ach na das sind doch schöne aussichten.
Du du kannst ja bei der eu und da kannst du ja noch dünnere sachen diskutieren wir haben ja diesen euro stability mechanismen
das ist auch so ein rettungsdienst was damals aufgelegt wurde das ding ist aber nur für die eurozone.
Also da wo der euro sozusagen als währung existiert.
Genau nicht für die ganze eu und da sind so viel ne also das ist ja da sind noch viele diskussionen zu leisten und viele bretter zu bohren.
Ich meine will er nicht zu viel reinlegen aber was ist auch schon wirklich bemerkenswert fand war die tatsache dass vor ein paar tagen der italienische präsident.
Konnte in der tagesschau interviewt wurde.
Das ist insofern was neu in meine wahl hast was haben wir denn das schon mal erlebt ne ich meine dieses ganze europa leidet natürlich immer noch extrem dadrunter erstmal,
sprach klar ist einfach,
es ist einfach ein shows man versteht die anderen nicht mal versteht deswegen die kultur nicht man hat nicht so viel einblick und schnell hast du halt diese mythen und schnell kannst du dich halt auch von solchen.
Medienkampagne ich sag nur so pleite griechen einfach in gefangenschaft nehmen lassen mental.
Wer jetzt sozusagen nicht in demselben maße denkbar dass wir sowas innerhalb von deutschland hätten.
Klar gibt's auch so vorbehalte und bremen macht immer schulden und so weiter aber der pleite bremer
ist jetzt sagen wir mal medial noch nicht geboren worden und wir haben aber eben diesen latenten rassismus irgendwie immer noch in uns drin und deswegen geht es an der stelle nicht so richtig voran,
trotzdem gibt's gegenbewegung gibt es immer wir hatten schon zumindest die debatte über
europäische parteien die dann sozusagen auch überall in europa mal für die europawahl antreten könnten das war nur so ansatzweise umgesetzt worden klar auch da hat sich deutschland wieder dagegen gewehrt oder vor allem die cdu glaube ich sogar
egal hat auf jeden fall auch sozusagen noch nicht so raum gegriffen aber da bewegt sich
was und wenn wir dann eben auch im rahmen wenn es auch erstmal nur im rahmen dieser krise ist aber ein zunehmenden maße ist auch irgendwie mal langsamer hinbekommen sollten so eine mediale europäische öffentlichkeit zu etablieren sicherlich noch ein langer weg gar keine frage will ich überhaupt nicht in abrede stellen
aber.
Tut sich schon was also das sozusagen jetzt dieses dieses business as usual wie wir das bisher immer gehabt haben auf politischer ebene sich langsam von dem entfernt was vielleicht die bevölkerung auch wirklich,
eigentlich gerne möchte weil wir haben ja gar kein interesse daran dass jetzt irgendwie italien komplett hops geht allein schon weil es.
Also nicht nur weil's europa ist sondern weil er irgendwie auch weil er nicht irgendwann mal hinfahren,
nach fünf jahren wenn sich wieder alle trauen tourismus zu betreiben festzustellen dass das dann sozusagen alles nur noch verbrannte erde ist.
Dann liebt uns keiner mehr in europa und wir dürfen denken wo wir hinfahren das wäre das will auch keiner ja.
Ich bin ich wundere mich auch immer viel langsamer ich meine gut das ist die eu ist ein großes konstrukt und das da.
Läuft auch jede menge falsch das kann man wenn man populistisch drauf ist.
Gerne ausschlachten wärmste wir haben in großbritannien die ganze debatte ja mitbekommen wie auf jeder kleinigkeit die in brüssel falsch war,
rum geritten wurde so okay da sind da noch sachen dazugekommen für die die einfach nicht stimmt genauso die einfach fake news waren.
Meister eigentlich sogar.
Ja
Das meiste was diskutiert wurde hat so nicht gestimmt.
Oder war zumindest übertrieben oder vor falsch dargestellt und manches war auch komplett ausgedacht was wäre aber.
Relativ selten bekommen ist wenn du die einmal wenn du einmal brüssel als sündenbock,
auserwählt hast und immer auf den rumhackst passiert halt auch die kritik im lande nicht mehr so richtig ne das ist sehr komisch ich finde dass das klappt auch manchmal total weit auseinander dass dann.
Das abgeschoben wird dass die verantwortung abgeschoben wird wir sehen es ja bei bürgerrechten auch häufig oder überwachung
gesetzen häufig wie das dann über brüssel eingestiegen wird und dann in den ländern nur noch abgenickt wird besser war natürlich programm ist mir was so geplant ist.
Wenn man das aber so macht muss man sich nicht wundern dass irgendwann brüssel ein schlechtes image hat weil die politiker der bevölkerung erzählen wenn die medien der bevölkerung erzählen dass brüssel das ja so wollte und dass brüssel das schuld ist.
Da bin ich voll bald ihr da fehlt dieses gegengewicht es fehlt irgendwie diese europafreundlichen.
Berichterstattung oder auch eine fundierte europafreundlichen berichterstattung und eine fundierte.
Europa kritik auch das gehört ja auch dazu der die eu nicht für sachen zu kritisieren die es einfach
gar nicht gibt oder die schlecht sind oder die in den ländern genauso schlecht laufen sondern die kritik da anzubringen wo sie hingehört
also jetzt zum beispiel bei so einer diskussion über eurobonds da muss man halt ganz klar sagen das ist eine große chance gewesen in der letzten krise.
Und die haben wir verpasst die haben halt verpennt da ein vernünftiges vernünftigen mechanismus aufzusetzen um gegen die nächste krise gewappnet zu sein und das ist ein versagen was auf europäischer ebene passiert ist.
Klar auch da kann man wieder sagen natürlich sieht die landesparlamente darauf schuld daran schuld natürlich haben da auf lokaler ebene oder auf landesebene.
Parteien angst vor populistischen europafeindlichen parteien die ist ja auch in einigen ländern schon an die regierung geschafft haben auch das darf man ja nicht unterschätzen.
Klar orban.
Das ist.
Man kann ein bisschen nachvollziehen warum manche dann so europa also so zurückhaltend sind bei europafreundlichen maßnahmen aber es ist natürlich ein fehler es sind ganz klarer fehler.
Die einigung vorantreiben.
Und nicht immer dieses länder denken bei eu-weiten themen haben das muss weg also wir dürfen das nicht auf länderebene diskussion sowas wie korona was in ganz europa auftritt darf nicht mit in landesgrenzen diskutiert werden das ist total bescheuert.
Genau und das bringt uns dann vielleicht auch zu unserem abschluss segment den blick über europa hinaus rona findet ja auch nicht nur auf europäischen ländern statt sondern.
Ist halt einfach mal ein globales thema und ich glaube wir werden wir leben jetzt sozusagen noch in einer situation wo sich gerade in europa etwas verschärft und maßnahmen ergriffen werden die andere länder dann noch erwischen werden und die sind dann teilweise noch schlechter aufgestellt
ich denke dann waren sie da medica et cetera man macht sich das überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen aber letzten endes dieser virus ist nun mal in der welt und der der der ist eigentlich auch schon überall angekommen und jetzt.
Dementsprechend wird er sich halt überall auch verbreiten.
Und wenn er sich halt nicht mehr verbreiten soll werden alle länder diesen look down vollziehen müssen wobei ich glaube das ist auch teilweise schon hast du zahlen darüber wie viele länder.
Jetzt effektiv schon auch wirklich runtergefahren haben.
Nein habe ich nicht habe ich auch mal nachgesucht habe ich aber nichts wirklich gutes zu gefunden.
Was man sagen muss auf der zeitlichen schiene haben zumindest die länder in afrika ein vorteil von vor uns weil da gibt's teilweise sehr wenig fälle.
Es ist.
Früher als in deutschland sind die grenzen dicht gemacht worden die flughäfen sind dicht gemacht worden du kommst nur noch vierzehn tage quarantäne ins land rein,
so 'ne ganz leichte hoffnung habe ich da dass sie vielleicht das besser handeln als wir.
Aber auf allen anderen ebenen sind die natürlich zigfach schlechter aufgestellt.
Also es gibt vielleicht noch einen punkt in dem die besser aufgestellt sind die afrikanischen länder die hat eine hammer erfahrung gesammelt also dich mussten erfahrungen sammeln mit der ebolakrise.
Die haben am laufenden meter erfahrung mit diesem problem weil es gibt halt in vielen ländern also vor allem in so einem zentralafrikanischen bereich da gibt's noch solchen problematiken die wir schon lange vergessen haben die da noch permanentes problem sind.
Das ist das schöne davon in diesem zusammenhang will ich sagen weil das verspricht ein wirklich trauriges
thema zu werden wir haben in den ländern dadurch dass die halt zu solchen haben und auch schon mit ebola sein,
pandemien ähnliche geschichte nicht global aber in den ländern wurde ja auch massiv dann look down gemacht not krankenhäuser aufgebaut und so weiter die haben eine gewisse erfahrung
damit auch das gibt so einen ganz leichten hoffnungsschimmer aber wirklich nur einen ganz leichten denn alles andere ist natürlich ein ziemliches desaster,
also wenn du da zahlen dir bei der oecd,
da gibt's eine hältst datenbank da kann man reinschauen die teilweise auch entwicklungscenter oder schwellenländer dazu hat und wenn du dir anguckst wie viel notfall betten die haben in dem land
ja da ist natürlich italien noch extrem luxuriös gegen ausgestattet und die haben schon viel zu wenige,
und von dem luxus hier wie hier in deutschland da brauchst du gar nicht darüber nachdenken.
Allein sieht die krankenhäuser mit dem nächsten mit der nächsten intensivpflege einheit die sind ja manchmal auch einfach fünfhundert kilometer entfernt das klingt ja schon da los und wie du dann die krise wenn die da wirklich ausbrechen sollte in den griff bekommen kannst ist mir völlig,
schleierhaft kannst du eigentlich nur hoffen dass man es schafft die quarantäne.
Früh und verbreitet einzuführen den look down früh einzuführen das haben wirklich viele länder gemacht aber auch das geht ja nicht,
ohne nebenwirkungen von stadtnah also das sind halt arme länder.
Ich sage mal das essen für die kinder in der schule fällt weg wenn du die schule zumachst so das sieht ganz einfache dinge und die familien haben oft nicht das geld das schulessen aus eigener tasche zu bezahlen.
Dann ist dann ist natürlich auch ein lockerer und der dann die ausbreitung der krise verlangsamt oder vielleicht sogar ganz verhindert,
ich bin jetzt mal super optimistisch nutzt er da nicht zwei die kinder haben da nichts mehr zu essen also du hast eine ganz andere probleme auf einmal.
Ja also so oder so wir stürzten hier wirklich auf ein globales problem hin und ähm ja es ist mittlerweile schon fast eine plattitüden wenn man sagt man kann ja noch gar nicht absehen wie lange das dauert.
Stellt sich natürlich die frage hat sich.
Bewährt sich dann irgendwie unser wirtschaftssystem an sicherer also ist jetzt so kapitalismus das beste was uns gerade passieren konnte oder ist das sozusagen noch ein ein ein brandbeschleuniger in diesem moment.
Brandbeschleuniger ich glaube ich bin ja kein kapitalismuskritik das muss ich an der stelle sagen da gibt's auch relativ wenige ökonomen die das sind,
weil ich glaube schon dass das system hat viele probleme also dieses grundsätzlich alle leute unter druck setzen und,
in richtung ausbeutung.
Ist ein grundproblem der wettbewerb kann halt an vielen stellen und wird halt auch an vielen stellen viel zu stark auf viel zu extrem wir haben eine sehr ungleiche vermögensverteilung,
innerhalb der länder aber auch über den ganzen planeten wenn du das alles betrachtet und da kann man natürlich sehr viel anders machen.
Auf der anderen seite muss man sehen der kapitalismus und die länder die richtig mitmachen in dem spiel.
Gerade in asien hatten in den letzten jahrzehnten massiver vermögenszuwachs also so komplett falsch kann der kapitalismus auch nicht sein,
es wäre natürlich extrem hilfreich.
Wenn wir bessere ausgleichs mechanismen hatten und da würde ich gerne nochmal afrika aufnehmen,
die haben wir nämlich nicht wir haben innerhalb der länder die ausgleichs mechanismen nicht die man immer unter dem namen außer dem schlagwort soziale marktwirtschaft gerne bringt aber sowas haben wir ja weltweit überhaupt nicht ne also.
Was wir an entwicklungshilfe ausgeben das ist ein witz und auch was jetzt in der krise ausgegeben wird für afrika was die welt
bank oder ähnliche institute
zur verfügung gestellt haben für die krisen bekämpfung in schwellenländern das ist ein witz da reden wir auf einmal wo wir in deutschland schnell über dreistellige milliarden reden in amerika sogar über billionen reden,
zwei billionen von der notenbank zwei billionen vom staat wenn du die ganze garantie mit einrechnest da reden wir in entwicklungsländern
teilweise nur noch über dreistelliger millionensummen zusammen gibt es natürlich auch eine zweistellige milliardensturm aber für alle zusammen und das ist ein
fit dann für drei milliarden menschen oder wie viele dahinter stecken die von diesem programm dann betroffen sind und mir wäre es lieber wenn wir eine marktwirtschaft hätten mit vernünftigen ausgleich man muss ja nicht die ganze marktwirtschaft abschaffen
weiß es gibt leute die ich bin auf der.
Aber wir brauchen stärkere und kräftigere und fairere mechanismen um die ungleichheiten auszugleichen und wir brauchen an so einer in so einer krise halt auch mehr solidarität.
Aber wir kriegen sie innereuropäische nicht hin mit eurobonds und weltweit sieht's ja noch viel übel aus.
Gut ulrich jetzt haben wir schon glaube ich über zwei stunden gequatscht hier.
Ich fand das eine ganz gute grundlage um überhaupt auch einfach mal künftige maßnahmen und entwicklung vielleicht zu bewerten würde mich freuen wenn wir da vielleicht zu gegebener zeit nochmal,
zusammenkommen könnten ich denke die ganze situation überfordert alle so ein wenig aber es ist natürlich auch immer eine gute gelegenheit anlässlich solcher vorgänger auch mal so ein bisschen den blick auf die welt zu schärfen und zu schauen okay was.
Was umgibt uns denn eigentlich so alles und naja die wirtschaft ist dabei ein ganz wichtiger punkt.
Vielleicht können wir da mal sprechen ohne dass gerade so eine krise wirklich wütet dann kann man auch ein bisschen mehr auf die grundsätzlichen sachen dann mal eingehen und muss sich immer die man betrachtet jetzt alles immer aus diesem krisen gesichtspunkt.
Ja zum glück kann man nicht immer krise aber kapitalismus ohne krise gibt's halt auch nicht ne also schon interessante.
Na klar aber ich meine krisen sind aber auch wirklich momente erhöhte aufnahmebereitschaft sonst kannst du halt auch viel reden,
aber du hast ja eben dann sozusagen auch nicht diesen geschärften blick und denke gerade gerade wenn irgendwas schwierig wird und dann hat man einfach auch den vorteil dass man eben merkt es auch an mir selber so ja dass dass dass man dann einfach sagst okay eigentlich habe ich das bisher noch gar nicht so richtig verstanden
trotzdem scheint das jetzt irgendwie auf einmal ein echter knackpunkt zu sein in der einen wieder in der anderen
richtung und deswegen finde ich eigentlich auch krise hat irgendwie auch was geiles.
Ich kann drauf verzichten.
Ich
ich würde auch lieber darauf verzichten aber ich ich stelle trotzdem fest so man wacht dann halt auch auf ne das ist so ein bisschen so eben wie man so wenn man sich irgendwie verletzt hat dann tut der arm halt weh so aber dann dann hast du eben auch so so eine hormonelle durchpumpen
die der sagt so war ja da muss aber jetzt echt mal genau mal hingucken so was ist denn eigentlich meine situation der man sich halt sonst irgendwie immer nicht so richtig bewusst wird so dass das das was ich eigentlich mal ansonsten werde ich natürlich jetzt auch gerne lieber drauf,
verzichten hat mich jetzt auch auf eine schöne entspannte sommergeschäft gefreut so könnte ein bisschen schwierig werden auf jeden fall wird's anders das steht soweit schon mal fest.
Ja man beschäftigt sich damit so themen mit denen man sich oder viele leute beschäftigen sich dann mit themen mit denen man sich sonst nicht beschäftigt ne wir sind ja jetzt auch alle hobby-meteorologe und epidemien.
Hey.
Geworden und vielleicht habe ich heute hier die basis gelegt für einen großen pool von neuen hobby kondomen.
Auf jeden fall also bei mir hast du auf jeden fall auch schon erfolge erzielt ich sag vielen dank ulrich.
Ja und vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei ukw ich werde hier auf jeden fall weiter interessiert in die welt fragen und dann schauen wir mal wie es bis ihr geht unserer kleinen.
Bist du.